wherever
i oh
my
yes
arena
so
it being uh five minutes after nine
we're gonna go ahead and open the first
hearing
of the criminal justice public safety
committee
treatment resistant depression because
of its
overwhelming success in helping those
who are facing serious mental health
issues
for so many especially those who are in
need like veterans first responders
those who are facing a diagnosis of
terminal illness
psilocybin therapy when
well administrated frustrated by a
licensed facilitator can help and that's
what we hope that you will um start to
consider and adopt
soon
one of the great and i think most
attractive things about psilocybin
therapy as the representative was saying
our
is to really focus on the therapeutic
aspects of of this amendment
and not the decriminalization aspects
that i'm here to speak to the
therapeutic components
is that societal therapy is designed for
just one or two sessions of use many of
us
have friends or family
who are on a daily regimen mental health
pills
who are trying to treat
serious problems
with pills that may or may not actually
do the job
one of the things that's exciting about
psilocybin therapy is that it's designed
for intermittent use
one or two sessions
throughout the course of an entire year
can actually help people break through
those cycles of depression and start to
find
health and wellness in a way that
actually improves their lives
i wanted to share with you a little bit
about the work that's going on in oregon
because i think it provides a road map
for the kind of regulated therapy that i
that
that i recommend to this body
um the measurement that passed in oregon
specifically designs
a container of regulated access
that
requires a series of licenses
and rules in order to actually have a
have a patient actually access the
therapy there are um the healing centers
where people will go and receive the
therapy are licensed the therapists and
facilitators who actually provide the
therapy are licensed
the individuals who will grow the
psilocybin are licensed and the testing
centers that are actually going to
evaluate the still assignment to make
sure that it's safe is also licensed all
of that regulation is designed to help
maximize and promote safety
the model here is
does not envision or ever encourage
individual at-home use these are
supervised
sections where an individual goes into a
center sits with this therapist for
hours
gets treatment
the therapy the drug wears off and then
they're allowed to go home
this isn't
this isn't a go pick up your drug at the
pharmacy and go home type of operation
that the the actual
the treatment is the therapy it's not
just the drug it's a combination it's
different than many other drugs in that
way
um
a couple of the other things that are
important about our approach to this
drug and we'd be glad to answer any
questions that the community may have is
that
there is no retail use there's no sales
there's no advertising this is this
isn't designed to be
as many people may
be thinking a cannabis 2.0
they're much different drugs and
designed for much different populations
the number of people who use psilocybin
is so small in comparison to the number
of people who might partake in a
legalized cannabis model
but the treatment here
it's not about recreation it's about
healing
and as i as i wrap up my comments to you
all today i just want to share a couple
more things about
about where i hope that this therapy and
treatment may go
many of the groups that we work with
are
organizations that deal with people who
are in deep depression or facing deep
trauma
we work with veterans organizations who
currently right now
raise money
to
send veterans to foreign countries
to actually get the treatment that they
need to treat their ptsd
we work with palliative care doctors
who talk about all of the drugs that
they have to treat people's
physical pain
at the end of their life
but the frustrations that these doctors
have that they have no tools
no drugs
attention on this important issue and
i've never recognized myself for a
question
what is the fda position currently
regarding physicians prescribing this
for treatment
representative roy members of the
committee
the currently psilocybin is in phase two
of its clinical trials with the fda and
so the fda has not approved psilocybin
for
prescription use
it
i i think most who are involved in the
fda clinical trials process expect that
for some
diagnoses probably treatment treatment
resistant depression is probably them
can find them
i do think that therapeutic uses
could serve an unmet need and i think
that if they come together
it will still benefit the health and
there being no further questions thank
anyone else wishing to speak on this
bill who wasn't signed up
there being no one i'm going to go ahead
and close the public hearing on hpp 1349
and i'm going to
always club a few minutes off the next
hearing
yeah we're gonna go ahead and reset this
bye
so
language
at this time we will
reopen the public hearing
and
uh we will begin on hb 1598
and the
chair recognizes representative abbess
thank you mr chairman and warning
members of the committee can everybody
i'm representative daryl abbas and i
represent rockhampton district 8.
now whether you support hp 1598 or not
i think that we all agree that the
federal government
really needs to address this issue
it's been about 13 years since the
federal government's
basically stopped enforcing the majority
of the cannabis laws
a short history lesson back on december
5th
1933 the 21st amendment was passed
and what that did is that repealed the
18th amendment
which effectively ended the prohibition
on alcohol
and when that happened the alcohol
industry was upside down
and one of the reasons for that is that
there were bootleggers running around
everywhere that was mostly organized
run by organized crime
in other criminal enterprises
to combat that problem
new hampshire began selling liquor
without overburdening consumers
with over taxation
this allowed consumers all over new
england to come to new hampshire
and purchase a superior clean product
that was tax-free that exceeded the
quality
of what you could purchase from a
bootlegger
while remaining while maintaining a
competitive price
we've watched one state after another
roll out recreational cannabis policies
where the
over-regulation over taxation
fueled the demand in the black market
rather than support a policy over
taxation
like our retail liquor sales i'm
promoting the idea of the new hampshire
selling
cannabis tax-free
now just to clarify if
this does not mean that the canvas would
be sold out a state liquor store
the understanding is that it would be in
the separate
retail store altogether
new hampshire already has this
infrastructure in place
with our liquor commission
we have the model and it's been proven
to be a successful operation
in respect to new hampshire state liquor
sales
in 2020
the net revenue
from the sale of alcohol in the state of
new hampshire
was approximately 175 million dollars
the gross sales
the gross revenue was approximately 750
million dollars
people come from all over new england
and they purchase
liquor from new hampshire because let's
it's been reported that approximately 40
to 50 of the sales of alcohol in this
data to out-of-state consumers
so i look at the recreational candidate
cannabis
as an opportunity for history to repeat
itself
and allows the state to maximize its
revenue before i get into the benefits
of that policy i want to just clarify
a few other issues
cultivation manufacturing
and testing and any type of
transportation would still remain
now we've this committee has been we've
every year i understand
before i became a
representative there's been several
bills
promoting recreational candidates
presented to
the committee
and again as for the benefits
look no further than the bill we
recently had was hb 237
the highest projected gross revenues was
around
36 million dollars
that is taking into consideration a five
percent transfer tax and nine percent
sales tax
which i would just put that out there
completely
if the state operates the retailer the
markup on the flower alone
depending on on the cultivator is around
if you land right in the middle that is
seven times the revenue
that the state would earn
if they sold it at a lower price
however
if you just matched it that way it's
seven times the amount that that would
put the gross revenue over 250 million
dollars
and that's not taken into consideration
the
potential for increasing the
out-of-state consumers
like we do with liquor it's also not
taking into consideration there's a
higher markup
on some
so the number of 250 million
i would i would present is a very
conservative figure
for the communities that are concerned
about cannabis the advantage of having a
state-run retailer
is that you're not you're unlikely to
have six seven retail stores in one
community
community where i come from where i live
sam there's one liquor store
procedurally there would be one
uh canvas retail store
a lot of a lot of constituents and
people i've talked to throughout the
state
who don't necessarily support
recreational cannabis
understand understand the atmosphere of
the state and they understand that
the polls show that about 80 percent of
the new hampshire residents support the
recreational policy but many people
support also not having 10 retail stores
so right now
residents in this state they're either
purchasing cannabis in the black market
or they're driving out of state
and purchasing cannabis
so that revenue is being lost to the
black market to other states
however we're still
to the extenders and people who believe
that there's social problems that are
related to camp recreational campus
we're still dealing with those problems
but not getting any revenue to actually
address those problems
that's why when it comes to the net
revenue the way that this bill is
drafted
any money that was drawn originally from
the general fund to actually
start this program would be repaid but
after that the next 25 million in net
revenue would go directly
to dhhs
to deal specifically with
drug treatment substance abuse programs
and issues relating to mental health
that's related to substance abuse
after that and
after that 25 million has been paid to
dhhs
90 of the net revenue would actually be
applied to offset the statewide
education property tax
and what that would do
one of the other concerns i hear from
from
constituents all over the state
is high property taxes
this is a reality when we have a policy
that we can implement we can make a
significant reduction
for property taxes throughout the entire
state
without compromising
funding for public education
it also puts us in a position in the
future to potentially increase funding
for public education without raising
property taxes
it's a reality it's right in front of us
and we can do it
and hb5 1598
puts it on paper
and it's been i believe this is a policy
just some other concerns that i've heard
and
there is going to be uh i've been
proposing an amendment
for some of the penalties for violations
of the possession limits
uh the bill as stated now hasn't listed
as a misdemeanors if you're using
cannabis in public or if you're
in a motor vehicle where some you're the
driver or another
passenger passengers using cannabis
it's listed now as a misdemeanor the
amendment would reduce those to a
violation for the first offense
uh if you're using canvas in a public
place
even though it's a violation any
candidate in your possession is subject
to forfeiture
again
a lot of concerns people raised was the
public
use of cannabis in a public place
i hope that that this would mitigate
that
and it would hopefully
not be a situation where you go to the
hampton beach you go
walking on trails into people smoking
everywhere
the other issue is if you're offering a
motor vehicle
i understand that there is no field
sobriety test that's a legitimate
concern
what this bill does it doesn't take into
consideration whether the driver is
impaired the driver is responsible for
what happens in their vehicle if a
passenger begins he's not their response
from
ensuring that passengers are also not
using cannabis but that would be reduced
to a violation as well
uh the original bill had it at a
six-month loss license it would be
reduced for three-month
loss license that and this that
provision was also in hpv 237
but i
reduced the loss of the license to three
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question
can you hear me all right okay
i'm
concerned
in looking at the bill
of the effect on young people you talk
about
the various allowances that can be used
or not used by
a younger person but what i'm concerned
about
is
we now make it legal
for an adult
uh to
possess
uh cannabis
what we're not doing or this doesn't
appear to me in in the bill
coming up with a sufficient penalty
for him
or her
if they were distributed
to a younger person i mean i've looked
at the cdc report
that says
the effects on younger people
for school and suicide
and things like that are devastating
so
where is the penalty
to prevent me if i
were to purchase cannabis
from giving it to an underage
child
and then
causing permanent damage to him uh you
thank you for the question that's an
excellent point
and i would love to work with you on an
amendment to include a penalty
i said a penalty that you find
satisfactory because
the age limit is going to be 21.
so anyone that's distributing marijuana
to a minor that's not prohibited are
allowed to possess it that is a crime
but
that's something i would be more than
willing to work with you on i agree
that and one of the ideas behind having
the state-run retail store
is
the state
when i've seen this with liquor
being raised in living
during my life here in new hampshire is
that they're very good at preventing
miners from purchasing from the store
directly
which is one of the reasons that i i
favor this policy so i share that
coming up with some sort of penalty to
the person
giving it to an underage
representative green
thank you mr chair
thank you for taking my question
uh isn't cannabis still a federal
offense
it is
and it what i mentioned when i might
when i was in the introduction
was that for about 13 years now there's
been a directive to not even enforce
their own laws
they're basically ignoring them so any
preemption argument that has been made
to the supreme court i would
suggest it still
and the reason why is that the federal
government has voluntarily
given up their control they haven't
repealed the law but they're not
enforcing it and that's the problem that
that by doing that that that handcuffs
a lot of opportunity in the camp whether
it's the medical side or the
recreational side but they're simply not
enforcing it so it is against federal
law but so is
uh medical use of cannabis
and we have medical cannabis facilities
we give them licenses
and just to put in perspective if you go
on a computer or a phone and you have a
fidelity account you can go buy shares
on the new york stock exchange cannabis
company
and no one gets arrested for
now i'm not saying that that's legal but
it's done
and that's what's happening
so this bill i understand is maybe
contradictory to federal law as is every
other
medical or recreational cannabis policy
or bill
whether it's law now a law enough state
where it's a drug
and drugs or
issues through
pharmacies shouldn't this be uh issued
well i think you're referring to the
medical use of cannabis this is purely
for recreational use
i understand the argument if it's for
medical use why is it not through
pharmaceuticals well the problem with
that if they've ever went that direction
is that it's again
the federal law
that's way outdated the non-enforcing
thing
it's illegal in the federal law so it's
insurance companies i'm not i know
there's some states that are trying to
cast laws to make insurance cover the
costs of medical cannabis
but again
that's its own issue here but without
the federal with the federal prohibition
in place
that's another example of maybe they
should take some action
if you want to write a joint letter to
our federal delegation
i'll prepare that with you
representative
thank you mr chair and
thank you representative for taking my
question so i'm
i'm was following along with you
and i did read the legislation prior and
i think the part that i'm
i think i want to just make clear so i
get it is that this would be
let me let me put i have two questions
so my first
this would be run
through the liquor commission and then
morph into its own commission
is that is that how i'm reading this i'm
i think i'm on page
oh these are not numbered
but the lecture commission indicates
this would sign candle sale and license
your responsibilities to the liquor
commission
including the responsibility to set up
the retail store operation
and then did i understand from your
testimony that then it would become
i can clarify
when i meant its own operation is that
if you walk if you go to a new hampshire
liquor store yes canada is not going to
be sold out of a new hampshire liquor
store however the regulation and
enforcement
and some of the
regulations
that apply to cultivators even the
retail advertising packaging there is
going to be some
that will be uh
oversaw by the liquor commission
and the rationale for that is
in respect to the bill we had hb 237 it
was basically cloning the liquor
commission
so we were basically making the same
operation doing the same thing
i looked at it as well if
you potentially could have run through
the same organization it would actually
not be a lot of duplicate
so that was the rationale for doing that
and there is some
the only issue with now is that there's
a rule making process for some local
regulations unless this bill would need
to pass and become law in order for some
of the more finer details of final
regulations to be made
there is a time frame and structure for
those rules to be made within a certain
my concern is that it would be
that cannabis
sales would be a state-run operation and
um and
from what i heard in your testimony that
there would not be
a tax
okay and and so
in looking
in part of the argument of like we are
we are an island surrounded by all these
other states that already
sell cannabis so we lose revenue that is
border jumping so in maine maine took in
fifty million six hundred and eighty
five thousand eight hundred and fifty
dollars in
taxes
and it doesn't look like in
massachusetts took in 81 million in
vermont took in 27 million
um
and
just from where i live um 20 minutes
away 25 minutes away from where i live
the city of kittery
is opening three dispensaries
and they had application fees for
representatives is there a question
there is a question thank you
mr chair um application fees alone were
000 so it seems like would we be leaving
millions of dollars in application fees
and millions of dollars of
taxes
that could benefit
the state
by
making it another
state funded operation where the
proceeds are pulled out i mean the
operation cost it looks like come out of
the general fund i i can answer that and
thanks
sometimes less is more and with our
liquor when you go to a new hampshire
liquor store there's not a state
sales tax on
a bottle of liquor
the revenue the state makes is from the
revenue from the sale
so that's where the state we would not
have to have a sales tax or put a
transfer tax on the cultivators and the
manufacturer would we would not need to
do that because the revenue is from
the sale itself
and the difference between
cannabis and liquor is that the markup
on canvas is a lot higher than liquor so
there's a lot more revenue to be made
in respect to the application fees i see
that the states
have these very very high application
fees
one example one state they had an equity
application trying to particularly
provide applications or licenses for
my people of minorities so they can get
into the industry
the application is still a million
dollar process
and i don't think that has equitable
affair to anyone and that's certainly
not shouldn't be the new hampshire way
the only person of wealth is able to buy
into an industry i understand you would
have to have it's still a startup it's
still going to cost money to actually
open a business
but some of those application fees
really prevent people from having the
opportunity to get into the industry
because we're making
seven times the revenue just compared to
what
what the market isn't just this just
talking just uh the flower product the
market on the
manufacturing products is much higher
so that's where the revenues need made
and that also means that we can sell at
a much lower price point like our liquor
so that would drive up out of state
consumers to come here right now people
come here you see that you see it all
the time on the highway people are
loading up their car with boxes and
boxes of liquor
and there's certain times if you buy 12
balls of wine at a time you get a 15
discount
so it's being done already and it's
proven to be a very successful model and
that's where the revenue would come from
and if you look at hb 237 the
anticipated revenue from out of state
consumers was very low
and the black market sales was close to
actually matching
the legal recreational sales
by being able to actually sell a product
at a competitive price with the black
market
i i'm just using logic here i don't
believe would make sense to buy
canvas in the black market if you can
buy a clean
product that's likely going to be
superior that has packaging labeling
it's been regulated for a comparable
price
that is the problem that i've had with
prior cannabis bills
is that if you over tax it and over
regulate it it drives up the retail
price
and you can go buy it for a fraction of
the price
in the black market and this this puts
in a position where
you're selling a better product
for a similar price that's a basic
market principle no reason why we
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for your
testimony
isn't it already a felony to give
marijuana to a minor
and then what are the penalties
for alcohol
from somebody that's 22 years old giving
my blue books in the brief my briefcase
is over there
it's already against the law i'm not
sure if it's if it rises to a felony
i do not know this but from what i hear
those small shops that we have
especially on the border
there's one down in massachusetts not
that far from the one
on the border in new hampshire
and the one in new hampshire is just
full of massachusetts cars
you know and you live in salem so i was
wondering if you drove by one of those
if that's the case
just to clarify you're asking if i drove
i've lived in salem the overwhelming
majority of my life
and if you look at first of all there's
a giant liquid store there there's tons
of massachusetts license plates in that
parking lot if you go to this
right where you get to where you know
the 213
exit 213 is which is right over the
third border
in new hampshire there is so many vape
stores that are all over the place
and there's tons of massachusetts plates
there
and one of the concerns i have with uh
is that if all if you had a recreational
candidate as policy as would you would
it be like we have with
vaping would they be 10
retail stores and sale
and i always had concerns about i
understand the town can pass zoning and
the communities can do that i always i
have that concern
and one of the things that i really
that's something i wouldn't support is
having that many retail stores so when
the state does it it's it's still
keeping a hand on the wheel
and i've heard some criticism by having
the state run it and oh it's a monopoly
but and if you have private retailers
they generally limit the licenses anyway
which is also a monopoly
so except for under our state
constitution having a private monopoly
is unconstitutional
so
thank you mr chair
um
i would just like to clarify your
response to previous testimony that
compared the model with taxes
and the model with markup
to each other
and it seemed like
when
you said we could make the same amount
of money
your model would allow for us also to
gain revenue
but isn't the markup also baked into the
state sales
of other states that
also have taxes or
will we actually be able to do that if
they also have a big markup for that for
their sales
in addition to taxes
thank you for your question
if i think i understood it correctly
you're worried about the markup
and how we can deal with other states in
massachusetts
first of all if it's not for medical use
it's a 20 sales tax
and
from what i from my research is if you
were to purchase one ounce of flour
it basically
uh cannabis in this you know leaf or
wheat in its leaf sub form
you're looking at about 300 an ounce
plus a 20 sales tax
and some products are even higher than
that
what i'm saying is in
with in new hampshire
we could sell it for a lower price than
that because the revenue
is going to be from the sale itself and
if you purchase in bulk again it depends
on the cost rate depends on the
particular strain that's why it's the
markups between 80 and 120 that is that
information was provided to me by uh
individuals individuals in the industry
of cultivation
so
the markup can be much higher but if you
if the price is too high
350 dollars first of all that's not
really consumer friendly nobody can
afford that
and that's why some people go to the
black market
if you you could legitimately sell that
for a hundred dollars less and still
make a significant
profit off the revenue and at the same
time that would encourage consumers to
come to new hampshire to purchase
cannabis right now people are driving
from new york
through new hampshire to maine to
purchase cannabis and they go to store
by store by store buying
the maximum amount they can then they
head back to connecticut they head back
to wherever wherever they're from
it's happening quite frequently
so
i believe that they'll stop in new
hampshire
i'll go ahead representative pratt
hello representative
uh
it appears that we're trying to model
after the alcohol business in new
hampshire
do you know the cost of alcohol in new
to society
are you talking society or for the the
liquor commission like the amount of
deaths
and the amount of the cost of the
alcohol business in new hampshire
i i don't
what i but and i listen i have i have
young children
and i live in the state i drive in the
state i share the same concerns of
everyone else
you know there is there is a public
safety issue that goes along with this
this summer
my family rented a place in salisbury i
wish they rented one in new hampshire
but
i had no say in that
and they have a
retail store there
and i i parked and i i sat and watched
for about half hour
i would say more than half of the cars
that pulled in had new hampshire license
plates
so a lot of the public safety concerns
that exist related to recreational
cannabis i understand
but
so i'm not i although this could
increase the amount of cannabis use it's
but i would imagine people from new
hampshire going there i talked to people
who've driven that's what they do
so
a lot of the public policy concerns are
still going to be there however we don't
have any of the
revenue to support
addressing those concerns that's why the
way this is drafted the first
25 million in in net revenue every year
is the goal
towards drug treatment drug prevention
and not just for cannabis for the
for opioids the state we're the only
state in the entire country where drug
overdoses has dropped
the last two years but even though
that's that even that's great but we can
do better this puts us in a position to
actually do better
and prevent overdoses as well
and actually treat people who are using
drugs or abusing drugs and help them get
better not just dealing with the
substance abuse the mental health side
of it often triggers a drug losses
so this is putting the state in the
position to fight that problem better
i understand it may sound hypocritical
to say you're using revenue from
candidates to do that but
it's going to i believe people get the
job done and if i sound like a hypocrite
i'll accept that but
i didn't want to leave my answer on your
question uh my question answered about
341 people die from alcoholic so new
hampshire is making a profit of alcohol
about 341 people in new hampshire that
died on an average representative pratt
that's a good question that's not a
question
so um
i won't talk anymore thank you very much
i appreciate it any suggestion we should
make alcohol illegal
well
not 340 people well we don't want to get
a discussion like that but uh 741 people
we reminded to the community we're not
um we can
uh representative abbas is a member of
the community anticipate we will have
work sessions and executive sessions an
ample opportunity to question and debate
amongst ourselves
let's uh let this witness go that way so
we can get other members thank you for
your time
mr chairman this is what the
representative from raymond understands
if a community has already prohibited
through zoning or local ordinance to not
permit a retail cannabis store from
opening which i understand the agreement
in new hampshire did that that would be
that would be honored if this bill were
to pass
my question is what
percentage and how long would it take
before we see a difference in property
tax
it's assuming that this became one today
it would likely take about two years to
become fully operational because
keep in mind the cultivation industry is
still going to be
private industry there's going to be a
licensing process for that and then it
will be a certain time where you could
then turn a profit on that so
i would say that in the following year
it would be a three-year window
if i could do it faster i would but this
is a complicated process but at the same
time i'd rather deliver it in three
years and not deliver it at all
thank you thank you mr chair and thank
you for taking the question
could i ask on the methodology on the
fiscal note
uh
section of this bill
there's a statement that said the bill
appropriates the sum of five million for
the biennium ending
23.
uh okay and then that goes on it says
the commission believes the five million
is not adequate to accomplish this
to accomplish the expectations set out
in the bill do you agree with that could
you explain that
so
i i
when that was this was prepared i
understand that is not going to be a
sufficient amount of allocation
to actually get
this operational
what what i understand is that there's
an amendment in the process here that
addresses the allocation issue
but i do agree i didn't factor in the
cost of
building out the stores
and that's information i didn't have
available to me at the time so it
wouldn't for me to then just make a
higher number i would have been just
guessing i thought that would be
irresponsible
the liquor commission is accurate i
don't have any reason to challenge or
just one more question uh
when they
started the alcohol business
they promised 10 of the profits to go
into alcoholism
mental health
because they knew that the increase of
alcohol to the community would have a
problem with alcoholism so there was a
ten percent off the profits that were
supposed to be put aside for that is
there something like that in this bill
for addiction
yes and
just when
alcohol and that happened it was in the
1930s
i i wasn't born yet
so i'm just going to explain in this
bill
after any money that's drawn from the
general fund
to get this program started it will be
repaid
to the general fund once that one-time
allocation allocations repaid
every year the first 25 million dollars
in net revenue
would go directly towards
substance abuse treatment
there are no further questions or
witnesses excuse thank you for your
testimony
the committee now calls chief bryanski
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee my name is john bryfonsky i am
the chief of police in bedford new
hampshire
going on 11 years now 43 years
in law enforcement
experience 27 of those as you may recall
from some previous testimony
with the federal government u.s drug
enforcement administration so i have
quite a bit of experience in dealing
with substance abuse
and law enforcement particularly with
respect to this bill
you have my written testimony it's quite
expensive i'm not going to repeat it but
i do want to cover
a number of important points that i
believe were brought up
by the chair and the sponsor of the bill
that public safety
needs to address and would like to share
with you members of the committee
so from a public pers
safety perspective i think the important
thing to think about
as i present the testimony is i
represent the embodiment of the
police officers the deputies and the
troopers
that deal with
the aftermath
of substance abuse as it relates to
cannabis use
here in the state of new hampshire
yes there are states that surround us
that have legalized and commercialized
cannabis
but as you can see the studies show in
each of those states that
cannabis use by our youth
in those states goes up
when it's legalized uh is it prevalent
now yes
but this bill will most assuredly
increase cannabis use
by our most vulnerable segment of the
population which is our youth
the public health elements and studies
are
substantial when it relates to
behavioral and medical disorders there's
no
medical society association
psychiatric or behavioral professional
association
in the state of new hampshire that i can
find
that supports
cannabis
commercialization
from a public safety perspective the
troopers and the sheriffs and the police
officers
deal with the aftermath of the wrecks on
the road the data is replete with
increased use
when states commercialize cannabis
and then it follows that increased
collisions occur
and increased fatalities on the roadways
occur that's what we have to look
forward to
uh if cannabis is commercialized
here in
the state of new hampshire and while
this bill
specifically addresses a prohibition
against
operating a motor vehicle while
consuming or vaporizing cannabis
we still struggle with no per se limit
with respect to the amount of
thc the psychoactive ingredient
in cannabis that causes
these
wrecks
so in those states that have legalizing
commercialized cannabis such as colorado
and nevada
oregon and washington
they have per se limits that allow law
enforcement to be able to charge there's
a threshold of nanograms per milliliter
that
are in those state laws that allow
public safety to charge people here we
can't even today
with two fatalities
in the town of bedford both
having operators that were responsible
with significant quantities of thc and
their system we could not
successfully charge and convict those
individuals
for driving while impaired by cannabis
so we look forward to increase
collisions increase wrecks on the road
that our troopers and officers and
deputies will have to deal with
um let's talk about
just for a moment
the
notion that if the state enters into an
agreement to
distribute cannabis commercially that
the illicit market will simply vanish
and go away
record and the information is replete
again
with every single state that has
commercialized cannabis the illicit
market has not gone away
the
economic forces that play in
the industry here will vanquish the
state's ability to be able to make
enough money
to pay for the regulation of cannabis
so from a public safety
perspective
from a medical perspective from a
behavioral perspective
and particularly from a law enforcement
perspective as it relates to the illicit
black market
or the listed market for cannabis which
will not go away which will only
proliferate here
what you're going to do is you're going
to turn law enforcement
on its side
and essentially this will be the
volstead act in reverse
because in those states they have to
spend significant amount of money to be
able to control the illicit market just
in this past week the state of oregon
has dedicated 25 million dollars extra
money
for law enforcement in the state of
oregon to address
the significant problem with the illicit
market
and
production
of illicit cannabis in the state of
oregon 25 million dollars we don't have
that kind of money in the state of new
hampshire to do that
not only do we not have the money we
don't have the troopers and sheriffs and
we don't have the police officers to do
it
so um
with
again in jackson county in oregon
the county commissioners have asked the
governor for the national guard to come
out and to address the proliferation of
the illicit black market
and finally let me just close by talking
about
um the public sentiment with respect to
cannabis legalization
polls are kind of funny things as we all
know the results of a poll generally
are
a reaction to the questions that are
asked
and so often times when polls are made
with respect to legalization
the questions are not asked in a way
that provides the respondent with a
different
way of responding concerning options
emerson college
which just released a poll that shows
that the majority
of americans do not support they oppose
commercialization of cannabis when given
other eruptions here in the state of new
hampshire as you all well know
no one goes to jail let me repeat no one
goes to jail for possession of cannabis
on small personal use amounts here in
the state of new hampshire no one goes
to jail
people that need or want cannabis by way
of a prescription from a medical doctor
are able to get it
so
given those options i dare say that if a
poll were commissioned again that the
results would be different
so again
i ask you from a public safety
perspective consider
the
behavioral and medical issues the
highway safety issues
and the law enforcement issues that we
are simply ill-prepared ill-equipped
in ill-funded
closing i'd just like to say that
in listening to representative abbott's
uh support for the bill that he is a
friend of law enforcement i i'd like to
say that here publicly
that
it seems that this bill
should have as a poster the dollar sign
as a law enforcement officer with 43
years experience
we need to rip the dollar sign off and
stop
talking only about revenue
and stop only talking about how much
money we're going to make
because in every state that's done that
they haven't made enough money to pay
for it
and take the dollar sign off and put a
public face
onto this bill
the public faces needs to be the faces
of young men and young women and
teenagers
the dead bodies that officers and
troopers scrape off the road
that's the public face that needs to be
on the bill not not a dollar sign thank
thank you chief i'm going to recognize
myself for a question real quick um the
sponsor talked about
the difference between the uh illicit
market and the um
what you said was that in some in the
states that have done this they have
been unable to compete
with the illicit market
in order to drop them out of the
business
are you aware whether or not
if they had a
if they were competitively pricing or if
they were adding a lot of tax in those
states
um because the sponsors seem to make the
argument that if we if we don't tax it
it'll remain low and therefore more
attractive to the
consumer
thus driving away from the private
illicit market if you have any thoughts
on that
thank you for your question uh yes i am
aware
there are various models
that are being used in california oregon
in the state of washington uh all of
those involve some degree of licensing
and taxation i believe that there is a
licensing requirement in
maine and massachusetts
i'm not sure about the tax component in
either one of those two states but
certainly there was a tax component in
vermont
in in vermont's first year
of
legal commercialization
their revenue production projections in
vermont fulfill
significantly short of what they
anticipated alaska was the same
california's
cannabis commercialization has failed
miserably
everyone is losing money in the state of
california they
consistently revise their revenue
production projections down
but again the california model
does involve significant licensing costs
and significant taxation costs here uh
in the model that's proposed by
representative abbas there still needs
to there still will be a market
uh component a supply and demand and
certainly
since the state is not going to enter
into the manufacture
of cannabis they're going to have to buy
it from someone
and
those particular folks
that are going to be manufacturing
cannabis for sale and the state adopts
some degree of liability when it sells a
product does it not
that that product is free of harmful
chemicals that has been tested
it's regulated
the state's selling a product just like
alcohol alcohol is tested and regulated
and is deemed
free of harmful chemicals
as the state sells it
that's a cost someone is going to have
to pay for that cost
so the market forces and play in all the
states while different are still going
to be in play here
and i can tell you that the people that
manufacture marijuana for sale
that
don't have to
be concerned about paying social
security
they don't have to be concerned about
paying workers comp they don't have to
be concerned about the environmental
effects
paying for water paying for electricity
and paying wages
consistent with the market
they will always
always be able to undersell and undercut
and eviscerate
a legal market because the legal market
as a good representative indicated
is built upon the premise that is going
to make a lot of money and we're going
to solve a lot of other problems it just
doesn't happen it's not it's not true
thank you
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
i was looking on page five of your
handout that you gave us and it talks
about uh suicide
talk ecology if i can say that word
right uh results by age group in 2019
it's from colorado
what kind of surprised me and there is a
question
is the alcohol and marijuana suicide is
about the same you know 51
and um
well i guess marijuana was 28 to 51
to uh
alcohol
can you get the results
for us
before colorado
legalized marijuana and can you guess
the results for what new hampshire is
i can try to get those results for you
mr representative and i will
i'll try to contact my colleagues in
colorado um
there may be some charts that are
publicly available that
show the increase in
um i think the chart that you have in my
handout uh depicts two age groups i
think correct it does right okay yeah
and there is a little bit of disparity i
think by one percent of an increase in
suicide
with cannabis and then as
an alcohol in one of the age groups
correct i think on the chart if i recall
by memory
there is a chart that's available i
think that does depict colorado's
increase in
completed suicides
before and after legalization i'll try
to get you that chart with respect to
new hampshire
unfortunately on we're not going to be
able to get those numbers and the reason
why is because suicides in the state of
new hampshire unless there are there are
some very unusual circumstances
with respect to the contextual nature
of the death
those are not those suicides typically
do not go to the office of the chief
medical examiner
and there are no toxicology reports on
i wish there were i i wish that
you would pass a law that would require
cost money
that to require a toxicology report for
completed suicides of all age groups so
that we could look at
what those numbers were when i was in
philadelphia
as the agent in charge for pennsylvania
we did look at those numbers
in the state of pennsylvania and in the
city
and at that time we were most concerned
about benzodiazepines
involved in suicide and the numbers we
showed for both marijuana and
thank you mr chairman and thank you
for your
testimony you're very informational on
that
at bedford high school if you can answer
this
how much alcohol is there compared to
marijuana being used by the students if
you know and what are you trying to do
to slow that down
anecdotally i can tell you that
since we've gone back to in-person
learning this year
um we've had a number
what's that number i
anecdotally so um this is i look at
every single incident every single day
in the town of bedford for 11 years so i
have these i have a conception of what
it is a hard number maybe not
but uh we've had
more
cases involving vaping
of cannabis products
and possession of cannabis products in
bedford high school
than we have in alcohol as a matter of
fact i can't recall
i can't recall a case in recent memory
uh over the past three or four or five
years where we've had a case involving
alcohol at bedford high school but we
have significant numbers
are they as high
as manchester or nashua certainly not
but they are concerning numbers in fact
we just had a few over the past couple
of weeks
at bedford high school and those were
vaping
uh situations involving vaping of
cannabis there was a chart in the
handout that shows a significant
increase uh and concerned with respect
to vaping of cannabis by young people
and on an increase when
cannabis has been commercialized
thank you
thank you mr chairman and thank you
chief for taking the testimony or taking
the question in for your testimony so
i live in dover and we have ample
opportunity to buy cannabis legally
most of the state population is within a
half hour of illegal canada's business
frightful
predictions you made about what might
happen have you seen
evidence to bear out
that
that's already happening because we know
that this is already accessible to most
of our state well sure i i would agree
and thank you for your for your question
and i think i'm going to try to answer
it this way for you
um
if you ever heard the the term spill
over crime
and that's what we're dealing with in a
new way with respect to being
the 101st airborne
of new england 101st airborne was
surrounded by the germans at the battle
of the bulge
and we seem to be surrounded here in new
hampshire by states that have
commercialized cannabis
and so there's a spillover effect
i i
often spar with the various chiefs of
the manchester police department of
spill over crime from manchester into
bedford
um
and so the same effect occurs here and
so in direct response to your question
yes
unfortunately the states that surround
us do have an impact
on the safety welfare and health
of the
of the granite state and particularly in
your area
and that's unfortunate
because maine
and
vermont
on the other side of the state
hasn't apparently taken a good look at
what the effects are
associated with commercialization as it
has
unrolled itself if you will in
colorado and washington
and oregon so yes there's a spillover
effect
chief thank you
let me rephrase that so the prediction
you if i understood correctly you made a
number of predictions about what would
happen in our state if this product
became legal
and the point i was trying to get to is
that this product is legal
in every state surrounding new hampshire
and that would suggest we know new
hampshire residents consume this product
that they purchase legally
and have you seen evidence and what
evidence exists
to bear out the predictions you made
since
the activity you described is already
happening in the state well to the
extent that i could talk about my
experience in the town of bedford we've
had a number of cases involving people
from massachusetts transiting through
just as i'm sure your police department
has in dover
from maine
traveling from massachusetts through
bedford to
keene state and other places with
cannabis products cannabis and fused
products
that are still illegal
and again that's the spill over crime
effect the prediction that i make is
based on
the data that we have seen from colorado
california oregon and washington and
alaska
where states have commercialized
cannabis and there has been an increase
in
use of cannabis by youth and adults an
increase in the attendant
medical
issues
chronic marijuana use disorder
behavioral disorders
and increases in
motor vehicle collisions and fatalities
in those cities so yes we've seen an
increase already as a result of being
surrounded by those states
but if
commercialized in new hampshire we will
see an even greater increase based on
the data that we've seen in other states
there be no further questions thank you
for your testimony
thank you very much for hearing me
the committee now calls aidan moore new
thank you mr chairman and committee
members good day
my name is aiden moore
i am the legal coordinator for the new
and i would like to offer some comments
on the bill
the bill legalizes the recreational sale
and use of cannabis
and previous bills on this legislation
of cannabis
have suggested creating a separate
commission to oversee the various
responsibilities
associated with legalization
this bill seeks to bolt on the sale and
licensure responsibilities to the liquor
commission
and establishes the responsibility to
set up retail store operation systems
regulate the licensing and enforcement
of the provisions within the bill
and provide the general fund with
revenues
that will be earmarked for various
agencies and public health and law
enforcement functions
the commission takes no position
on which organizational approach
to the legalization would be the most
effective if the bill were to become law
and the commission does not endorse this
bill
and takes no position
on the policy questions that are part of
the bill
and with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions you might have about the
fiscal worksheet we have provided
to you
as requested by the lba
there you see no questions i give you a
committee now calls lieutenant bill
good morning thank you for hearing my
testimony
many of the same uh concerns that the
division of state police has
have already been addressed by chief
prefonsky in his testimony
but we just would like to go on record
to say that if if this bill was passed
if the legalization of marijuana
does take place we do believe that there
will be an increase in
the potential of crimes an increase in
the
potential of impaired drivers and all
the things that go along with that
toxicology testing
an increase in
investigations involving the black
and any related crimes to
cannabis or
those types of
organizations
that's uh that's all i have that you've
covered covered most of it
um could you could you possibly just
repeat the last sentence into the mic we
really didn't pick up anything you said
there yeah that's fine um and i
apologize for that uh representative
um the the division of state police uh
just wants to go on record for this bill
most of the things were covered by chief
profonsky the concerns that we have
but the increase in impaired drivers the
increase in potential investigations
involving black market sales will have
an impact on law enforcement and the
public safety of our state
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
there's been some talk
about and i think you even brought it up
that there could be more illegal
activity
you know with illegal marijuana
i know the state
collects about 350 plus million dollars
is there illegal activity
in the state with alcohol
you know there's people selling it and
you know out of their trunk and
you know for illegally you know trying
to avoid taxes and everything else and
making it cheaper
i personally have not dealt with uh with
a situation like that i don't have uh
i don't have any knowledge
thank you but you do have knowledge that
there is illegal activity with marijuana
or there's going to be an increase in
illegal activity with marijuana
that start that that's our opinion that
we believe that that
possibility exists that there will be an
there'd be no further questions thank
i i think my pink card is for my hearing
on my bill at noon
i stand corrected
since i'm here as a member of the house
representatives
i support this spill
uh thank you mr chair i'm uh
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
uh by and large we're an older
established community
and uh legal cannabis is is not
really an issue amongst my uh direct
constituents
um
it's it's been over 40 years since it's
an issue i really cared about but
um i i have cared consistently
about the role of government and the
role of government in
uh intervening in the individual lives
of citizens
and this is an example i think of
government needing to reassess
its relationship to the people relative
to their
their freedom to interact with a plant
whether 1598 is exactly the right way to
go or not i'll leave that to the
committee
but as it was mentioned uh we're
literally
surrounded like the 101st airborne
division
by states that it
where recreational marijuana is
legal
and
it was described as spillover crime
i would describe it as
we are now intentionally
enabling and
preferring
a black market
to service the demands of the people who
want to use cannabis
and black markets are bad for a lot of
reasons
um
most of them i i'm sure the committee
members individually know black markets
are not good
they vomit crime uh and other
systems abuses
so um but i think we have a new threat
from
the black market and that is
we have so much fentanyl pouring over
our
southern borders
that
in other states it's become
common to lace
uh
a street pot with fentanyl and
as we all know
that's a very dangerous thing it's a
great way to get somebody addicted it's
also a good way to accidentally kill
people
and so i i think
we're now hitting a
public health aspect of having
marijuana that's available
that people know is not adulterated
so i i think we should be doing this i i
don't know if i said i was four to 1598
certainly in support of the
general direction
a year now three years ago we had a bill
related to
in-home cultivation
and i had an opportunity to talk to
the most senior elected official
representing the state of new hampshire
and that individual
said to me that in-home cultivation i
know that's not the point of this bill
but just the the i think the quote is
apt
um
that that individual said if we allowed
this
there would be chaos
and that's when i said
to him
um
a lot of people refer to that chaos as
freedom
and so
um
i've thought about
that exchange for two three years now
and i really do think uh the attitude
that we have to
control
people's experiences with a plant
the times the times past
you know talking to my dad before he
died you know pot in his uh uh social
group
was popular in 1948
okay this isn't really going anywhere so
with that i'll take questions if there
thank you
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you so much for the opportunity to
testify today my name is frank kennedy
i'm the policy director with the aclu of
new hampshire
i want to talk about a couple things
around racial disparities and just the
overall impact of marijuana
criminalization on people but uh after
hearing the previous testimony i just
wanted to correct the record on a few
issues that i think would be important
first
excuse me the witness could you possibly
speak more directly into the mike and
louder please we're not picking you is
that better that's much better thank you
i apologize um
so i
remember back to when legalization
efforts first uh first got started with
colorado and washington state and what
we heard from those opposing those
efforts was what we heard earlier in
testimony that would increase youth use
to increase traffic fatalities it would
increase crime and now we have the
benefit of data we have the benefit over
a decade of data in some circumstances
and what we've seen is those projections
have not borne fruit
and so i just really want us to focus on
what actually the data shows and so
particularly i know there was a lot of
conversation about youth use um
there was a study and all these are
cited in the testimony or in the handout
i gave you all
but there was a study in the journal of
american medical association uh back in
july of 2019 that found that
recreational marijuana laws were
associated with an eight percent
decrease in the odds of youth marijuana
use
and a nine percent decrease in the
amount of frequent marijuana use by
youth
and so again the data does not support
the conclusion that moving towards
recreational use in new hampshire would
increase traffic fatalities increase
crime
increase youth use etc
it was also argued there'd be some type
of spillover effect of crime and so i
just also want to clarify the record on
that issue
if you go back
looking at the last three years of data
we have in
new hampshire in terms of group a crime
rates
crime has reduced between 2018 and 2020
by 14
and so if there was some type of a
spillover effect i assume we would see
that in the data the data shows the
opposite in fact
and so getting back to the core of my uh
concerns with marijuana criminalization
in new hampshire
so a single marijuana rest you know we
have we've we've definitely reduced the
number of people being arrested we've
gone from about
2 800 arrests or so
in um
in 20
to about 1400 arrests or 1500 arrests in
but for each of those marijuana arrests
the collateral consequences can be huge
while they may not go to jail if they're
a kid on student financial delay they
can lose their student financial aid
they can lose access to housing
employment
the collateral consequences can live
with someone for a long long time after
arrest and so again this is something
that is harming the residents of our
state
in addition the aclu conducted an
economic analysis of marijuana
prohibition in 2010 using 2010 numbers
new hampshire was spending about 6.5
million dollars every year on just the
enforcement of marijuana laws of
possession laws not sales possession
laws
and so because all those arrests revolve
a judge clerk law enforcement officers
prosecutors etc
we have about half the number of arrests
in 2020 as we did back in 2010 and so
we're spending still about 3.25 million
dollars every year on just the
enforcement of marijuana possession laws
alone
and again the enforcement of marijuana
laws across the country new hampshire
not excluded are enforced with a
staggering racial bias
in 2020 black people were 4.8 times more
likely to be arrested for marijuana
possession than white people
and marijuana is a great opportunity for
us to actually look at racial
disparities because we know from
national data that black people and
white people use marijuana at roughly
the same rate and so we can do apple's
samples comparison
and so in 2010 we were at 2.6 times more
likely so not only had we have a
horrible disparity but our disparity has
gone in the wrong direction by 46
in the last decade
and in some jurisdictions in manchester
manchester half of all marijuana arrests
since 2020 were black people
that's a 13.9 times more likely rate in
manchester city pd and conquered 5.8
times more likely
and so again we think this this law
obviously we think there would be some
improvements to the law around edibles
around personal consumption and personal
growing but we think this law is very
important this bill is very important we
supported it and thank you all for your
representative
i had a question uh about your studies
the cost
if you go online you can look at many
many studies that colorado was legalized
marijuana a long time ago
it cost them
more money than they generate
and you said that that's not true
the cost arguments i was making are in
terms of the enforcement of marijuana
possession laws
and so the prosecutors tops you know etc
that that fall and so our study our
analysis that the aclu did back in 2013
looking at 2010 data was purely around
the cost of prohibition of marijuana
possession and not revenue collection et
cetera okay
so this bill has been sold as a weapon
i'm sorry
yeah this is being sold as a revenue
maker
but in colorado it costs 4.50 for every
dollar generated so it's not a revenue
maker in colorado i have not seen that
i've seen the opposite in terms of
there you go for the questions thank you
for your testimony thank you sir
the committee now calls daryl eames
thank you can you hear me okay yeah
excellent
my name is daryl eames and i'm the
founder of the new hampshire cannabis
association
our association was formed to support
educate
organize and connect the industry when
it arrives and we've been doing just
that in anticipation
our members include labor investment
entrepreneurs professionals
and ancillary services
and we're ready to get to work
today i'm here to represent new
hampshire's worker business and industry
specifically
on behalf of the association and our
members let me thank you for your time
and your tremendous effort in fighting
for cannabis legalization for new
hampshire
we recognize and appreciate your hard
work and we're here to support you
i'd like to start by saying that we
generally support legalization at a
minimum but of course we prefer to see
legalized commerce come with it
if that's in the form of a bill that's
great
if that's in the form of a
constitutional amendment so be it
over the last few years i've had the
opportunity to read many of the
candidates cannabis legalization bills
much of the discussion seems to be
focused on projected windfalls for the
state
however in our opinion this limited view
doesn't even begin to tell the entire
economic story
cannabis touches almost every industry
from agriculture and farming
to trades and transportation
to administrative and professional staff
there are opportunities for all who wish
to participate
there's a much larger tangible economic
benefit
new hampshire's hard-working residents
directly
and in addition to the use of state
funds
this is about real economic opportunity
for our residents
and in our opinion failure to bring the
recreational cannabis industry to new
hampshire
is a failure to provide more paths to
prosperity for our residents
this is important
and what this means
should be considered as you debate these
bills in these constitutional amendments
in my capacity as the founder of the new
hampshire cannabis association and in my
work
on a national level i've spent years
talking with operators all over the
country
owners in california tell me how over
regulation and taxation is devastating
their industry and propping up the black
market
operators in states with artificially
limited licenses share this cause
license fees to mushroom to a million
dollars in some cases
my contacts in massachusetts they laugh
at us they don't think that we have the
will that we can work together to
legalize cannabis in the state
i think it's high time that we prove
them wrong
but in doing so we only have one chance
to create an adult use market
and it's important that we get it right
focus on low regulation low barriers to
entry
low taxes
these are going to be critical and are
critical in our formulation
as i mentioned we're supportive of
legalization generally
however i'd like to share the following
as a special message to our legislators
and our governor
no one really wants to be forced to
purchase cannabis from the government
the retail experience should be as
varied and unique as the operators who
run them
if the government wants to fairly
compete
in the sale of cannabis
in the free market that would be fine
in fact i think having cannabis
available at something at the equivalent
of a state liquor store
is an option that many consumers would
choose
but the bottom line is that consumers
should be required to purchase from the
government more importantly our
residents deserve the opportunity to
compete
in the retail space
so on behalf of the consumers workers
and entrepreneurs of the state
we request that you amend hp 1598 to
ensure free market competition and
opportunity in the retail segment of the
cannabis industry
any questions
representative pratt
i have a question uh
you seem to be right on top of the
farming really have a good handle on
that
50 years ago
an organic material called tobacco
farmers in the south started selling
tobacco
and it was supposed to have a calming
effect
and people were supposed to feel good
about smoking cigarettes now we know 50
60 years later cancer is increased by it
do you see
cannabis in smoke is any different than
tobacco
i do in most cigarettes i think there's
over what 20 40 different chemicals that
are in there
anytime you combust
an organic material that there are
secondary effects from the smoke in the
carbon
but that's also why edibles are
important that's why vaping is important
that's why access to
other methods of consumption are
important yes
there will be no further questions thank
sir do you have a copy of that written
thank you mr chairman and members of the
committee for holding this hearing today
for the record my name is ross connolly
i'm the deputy state director for
americans for prosperity here in new
hampshire
uh we are currently neutral on hb 1598
however we are in support of ending
cannabis prohibition and we commend the
the sponsor of this legislation and the
committee for their
work to finally try and end uh this sort
of charade that's going on with new
hampshire being
surrounded by legal cannabis states on
an island
of prohibition if you will
um
although we'll likely be last in new
england to legalize cannabis for for
adults
for recreational use we have the
opportunity to learn lessons from uh the
surrounding states of what what went
well what did not work well
uh and and we do i do have some written
testimony to hang it hand out afterwards
of just some do's and don'ts of lessons
that we've picked up from around the
country of of what's to work to in a
roll out to a legal market and what uh
some of the top line issues we have with
this bill really have to do with
competition and access
to the market uh currently hp 1598 as
has been mentioned
only allows sales in uh state-run stores
uh we're concerned about the market
being able
uh to get off the ground uh
while
state the the liquor commission will
have to go through a rule making process
there will be an extended time where
they have to find
leases for storefronts things of that
sort and and
uh cannabis is not as simple as many
make it out to be difficult to grow and
it's very expensive to open up and get
started at cultivation
facility uh our goal should be
to quickly reduce the influence of the
the black market
and uh make sure that we're out
competing our neighbors
uh to do this we need cultivators to get
started and
start growing product and producing
product so that we're increasing our
supply
and and therefore lowering price
uh we should
allow cultivators to sell directly to
consumers
outside
out of their their facilities
so that we we increase that supply
before
state stores open so that it's an easy
roll out and and we avoid any
roll out that's fraught with problems
competition and supply is what lowers
price
uh
and and we believe that this is a a way
that we can
uh find a middle ground to having state
stores but having that access to the
market before those those are open
lastly the safest way to consume
cannabis is edibles uh
there's a lot of
fear-mongering around them but it
you you
when you take an edible you know exactly
the dosage amount that you're getting
and you're avoiding any consequences
from consuming cannabis through through
us smoking which obviously any time you
burn organic products there there can be
consequences with that so we encourage
the committee to look into
allowing the state stores
to
sell edible products to
all consumers of age
in the states stores
and to allow those manufacturing
facilities to distribute
uh out of their facilities for those
same exact reasons as the cultivators so
that we increase supply lower price and
are prepared to open
those uh those recreational stores
uh and for those reasons uh
we encourage the committee to look into
uh maybe amending the bill uh but again
we commend the committee uh for your
work to finally try and solve this
problem uh with that i'd be happy to
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony thank you for your time
we now call emily shanahan
good morning i'd like to start by
thanking the community for the
opportunity to speak today in opposition
to hb 1598
my name is emily shanahan and i'm a new
hampshire certified prevention
specialist and coordinator of the new
hampshire chapter of smart approaches to
marijuana
there's been a significant
evidence i'm sorry to interrupt you
could you please speak directly into the
mic
yes
is that better okay there's been a
significant body of evidence that
demonstrates the health safety and
economic harms of marijuana legalization
far outweigh the perceived benefits
we have both decriminalized and
legalized marijuana for medical purposes
so why do we now need to legalize for
recreational use
with our state facing a pandemic opioid
crisis and youth vaping epidemic why are
we considering legalizing another
addictive drug that has severe negative
impacts on youth families or communities
in our state
virtually every medical and psychiatric
association in america strongly opposes
legalization and commercialization of
marijuana in new hampshire this includes
the new hampshire medical society
american academy of pediatrics in new
hampshire catholic medical center
new hampshire community behavioral
health association new hampshire public
health association and the new hampshire
nurses association among many others
just recently the u.s surgeon general
issued an advisory on youth mental
health stating mental health challenges
in children adolescents and young adults
are real and they're widespread
by legalizing and commercializing
marijuana we are contributing to that
problem
marijuana use has been linked to
depression anxiety thoughts of suicide
suicide attempts suicide and addiction
we need solutions not more problems
prevention is more urgent today than
ever before as treatment for youth is
almost non-existent
just recently one used in our central
new hampshire region was admitted to a
local hospital for three weeks waiting
for a bed at hampton hospital for
inpatient treatment
marijuana potency has tripled in the
past 20 years and sends more youth to
treatment than any other drug
estimates from research suggest that
those who start using marijuana before
the age of 15
are 70 percent more likely to experience
addiction because their brains are
undergoing rapid development
hb 1598 designates 25 million dollars
from marijuana sale proceeds to
prevention treatment and recovery but
why designate funds to a problem when
we're creating a problem that's
preventable
let's just not create the problem at all
we need to prevent drug use and not
encourage it
some have raised the issue of growing
public support for legalization as
reflected in a unh poll
as of polling the answer depends on the
question that's asked
and this poll asked essentially a yes or
no question and compared marijuana with
alcohol and tobacco
but when voters were given a choice
between decriminalization
medical and recreational 53 percent of
new hampshire voters opposed
commercialized marijuana as reflected in
a recent emerson college poll which you
have attached a better metric of public
support is the not in my backyard effect
government reports from the legal states
show 72 percent of municipalities in
colorado have banned pot shops 80 in
california 65 in massachusetts and 60 in
oregon the remaining legal states have
seen similar numbers
many people point out that we are
surrounded by legal states but does that
mean that we should join them
new hampshire is an oasis let's work
together to keep new hampshire a state
to be emulated through proper public
health promotion
i ask that you please suppose hb 1598 to
help keep new hampshire a productive
oasis that promotes the health and
safety of its citizens thank you for
thank you for taking my question
i'm interested in the statistics that
you
i've looked at the statistics um the raw
numbers
and they don't but i saw it doesn't
indicate that
the respondents said that they were
opposed to
legalization
um
in fact the the poll that i looked at
showed that less than 14
of respondents said that they would like
to keep cannabis illegal
can you clarify do you have the actual
yeah
a chart with two bars on it
and one says full marijuana legalization
and the other one says other
non-legalization marijuana policies and
when i looked at the raw data for this
emergency poll
it's my understanding that
the
um the actual possible responses that
someone could give on this poll where if
they support decriminalization if they
support medical cannabis
if they support legal legalization
and then
the other option is that they could say
the difference between
being opposed to legalization
and being in support of
decriminalization
and why four options
in this poll were boiled down to two
two bars on this chart it's it's very
confusing thank you for taking my
question thank you
um so according to this poll um when
given those options that you had
mentioned
um the majority of the people that were
polled chose that they were not they
were opposed to commercialization of
marijuana
may i have a follow-up please
yes but the
representative is reminded not to argue
with the witness
thank you for the reminder
and thanks for allowing me to have a
follow-up it'll be my only one thank you
um
is there a difference between selecting
one of three types of decriminalization
is there a difference between that and
opposing legalization in your opinion
in my opinion oftentimes a lot of people
get confused so when we asked the
question in this way by giving the full
options the respondents
said they were majority opposed to
commercialization of marijuana
thank you for taking my question thank
there being no further questions thank
you
good morning and thank you for the
opportunity to speak today and testify
in opposition to hb 1598 fn
for the racket my name is deborah narrow
and having served in the new hampshire
house for three terms i fully appreciate
the many difficult decisions that come
before you have immense respect for your
work
last week i convened 10 of the new
hampshire drug free
community coalitions in a jointly signed
educational letter
uh to help inform your decision making i
believe that was mailed and you should
have received that last week however i
did
attach that to my written testimony
i am testifying today as executive
director of katie a prevention
non-profit serving the central new
hampshire public health region
science and evidence-based practices
are the driving force behind our work
i have two decades of experience in the
substance abuse prevention fields
we believe it is our responsibility to
call
attention to the growing science on the
risks of cannabis use and the urgent
need for informed decisions when
considering the impact of public safety
policy on on our children
the scary truth is our kids are in a
crisis and we are very worried our
region's 2019
central new hampshire yrbs survey
indicates that our youth reports
significantly higher levels of sadness
hopelessness and suicidal ideation than
statewide damages
local youth use of marijuana and vaping
have increased significantly putting our
children at even greater risk of income
youth marijuana use in our region is
significantly above statewide averages
with one in three youth regularly using
the drug
this hasn't always been the case
in 2015 our youth were significantly
below statewide averages in marijuana
use
following the opening of the alternative
treatment center in plymouth we have
seen a 65
increase in use
youth are getting the message that
marijuana is medicine
so it must be good for
them when science tells us the exact
opposite is true
marijuana use is consistently linked to
poor mental health outcomes with youth
being at greater risk for anxiety
depression and and addiction
daily marijuana uses under age 17 are
less likely to graduate from high school
more likely to use other drugs more
likely to to develop addiction and more
likely to attempt suicide
high potency thc increases these risks
and our kids are getting the wrong
message from therapeutic cannabis and
recreational legalization will only
exacerbate this problem
no amount of legislative safeguards can
protect the most vulnerable among us
as promises made and unkept on alcohol
tobacco and therapeutic cannabis a test
let's consider drug endangered children
in 2021 new hampshire poisoning control
received calls involving 22 children
under the age of five who were exposed
to marijuana
four of those calls involved toddlers
from our region who were admitted to our
local hospital in thc induced comas
they had ingested high potency thc
gummies
if we cannot keep thc out of the hands
of toddlers how are we ever going to
keep it out of the hands of our teens
with legalization more cannabis
there will be more cannabis on the
ground resulting in more emergencies
we should be paying close attention to
the experience of legalized states
to inform our policy making
it's so bad in colorado the governor
recently signed a landmark marijuana
reform
reform bill
drafted by the speaker of the house
both were early pro-marijuana advocates
fire's remorse has set in
they rushed headlong
into legalization without a full
appreciation of the science
i read the details of hb 15
that seeks to commercialize a high
potency addictive substance that is not
fda approved and spends millions of
taxpayer dollars set up and run retail
outlets
and in the fiscal note the new hampshire
department of safety and state police
warn the bill would likely result in an
increase in impaired drivers
toxicology testing black market sales
and the investigation of crimes such as
robbery
burglary and theft
wouldn't our state be better served
preventing rather than encouraging
drug abuse
i ask you to please protect new
hampshire's children by voting hb 1598
fn
expedient to legislate
thank you for consideration and i'm
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony i'm very disappointed
but if you ever have any questions just
give me a call thank you thank you
the company now calls the honorable joe
handman
thank you members of the committee my
name is joe hannon
i'm a former state rep retired doctor
and i was also a member of the public
who is on the uh new hampshire
commission to study the legalization and
taxation of marijuana i believe it was
2018.
we submitted that report
we spent a year
every every few weeks
listening to people from all over the
country that have legal
cannabis and marijuana programs
from colorado to massachusetts you name
it we talked to pretty much everybody we
can get a hold of
um
this is pre teleconferencing recovered
so we had to do a lot of it that way so
we got a little experience doing that
but
anyway uh i checked off that i was not
in support of this bill in particular i
i'd rather say i'm neutral this bill the
way it's written but i am the my main
issue is the fact that the state would
have control over the sole sales of
cannabis
um
you know there are about a quarter of
the states in this country are liquor
control states that sell
you know only sell they're the only ones
allowed to sell spirits
um there's some evidence that shows that
that does decrease uh drinking usage of
all kinds but it's not a very large
decrease in
drinking
cessation that not cessation but
drinking usage that's shown
new hampshire
like all those other states put the
liquor commission in charge of selling
it so we wouldn't have so many people
drinking alcohol
it was a response that the prohibition
has had when prohibition was repealed
back in 1933
to say okay well we can't stop it even
though everyone's not everyone but many
people are doing it and we can't enforce
it
to keep problems with the current
prohibition it's it's happening and it's
unenforceable there are many people that
are using it that are never able to be
arrested for it and and rightfully so
because it's it's foolish to even try at
this point
um we are this island of prohibition
surrounded by other states uh i don't
think
comparing us to uh you know those other
states to the nazis is actually a
relevant uh
you know uh
comparison but
i like the idea that we are an island of
freedom and that's in that's uh that
would we were we could be an island of
freedom in in the rest of the country in
new england if we joined the other
states
so
there are some big some arguments we
always heard about why it shouldn't be
commercialized
uh big cannabis is always that word
that's thrown around we don't want to
commercialize it because more people
will get it
i talked to every single person that
came and testified at the liquor at the
study commission for this
that was against it i said you know are
kids having any problem getting it oh no
it's everywhere i was told
kids have no problem getting it's
everywhere it's in the schools it's easy
to buy it's actually easier
in some cases than to buy alcohol which
has to be carded in most of all
establishments in the state
um the other argument was that it's a
gateway drug people are using this and
going on to do other drugs now the
younger people do any substance whether
it's nicotine alcohol tobacco it is not
a good idea i'm not saying children or
young adults should do this i think you
should wait as long as possible i've
been recovering myself for over 30 years
i have a 15 year old son who has friends
that smoke and they drink more than
smoke than drink because it's harder for
them to get alcohol by the way
and he says well what about me what
should i do i said
i'm not even going to tell you not to do
it i'm going to tell you not to do it
now
because it's you know i'm your dad and
it's not a good idea
but if you get to be older and you want
to do it give it a try but give it some
time because there are dangers
associated with it and i think this is
one thing that was missed by a lot of
people on both sides of the debate
some people like to say it's a totally
harmless substance and others say it's
the you know going to cure cancer and
all these other things
it's
neither of those things there's
something in between alcohol was also
considered medicinal for a long time
during prohibition
i was
talking to a former person from liquor
commission one of the enforcers
enforcement officers who actually has an
obsession an antique copy of a medicinal
alcohol prescription pad for the state
of new hampshire so this is not a new
occurrence you know we've had medicinal
alcohol in the past we have medicinal
but we do have big cannabis already it's
in the in the form of illegal sales
it is completely unregulated they don't
check ids kids have no trouble getting
it from someone and you also hear about
the gateway you know i talked about the
gateway
people think that if they start early
they're more likely to other have other
substance use problems as later in life
the earlier you start doing most
addictive substances it is true it is
harmful later in life
but
there's not a lot of consensus on what
really is the gateway whether it's
actually something that causes this drug
causes that you could say everyone who
drinks milk becomes this is an adult
well it might be true but it doesn't
mean that it's a
a definite result of something happening
so
you know the gateway is more likely that
people buy an illegal substance from
someone are more likely to buy another
illegal substance from that same person
so if someone is
you know i've
i don't drink it anymore but i never
went into a bar and asked the bartender
to buy cocaine or marijuana they just
won't sell it to you because it's a
legal establishment if you talk to
someone who's selling cannabis on the
street and say hey do you know where i
can get some cocaine or fentanyl
they probably know that and i'm sure
they'll give you a referral you're not
going to see that in a regulated market
whether it's state or commercial and
retail
we heard limiting licenses limiting
licenses would be a problem if the state
didn't do it it doesn't have to be a
problem there's a way to do this
equitably to have people that are
allowed to operate any business in new
hampshire should be allowed to operate a
cannabis business in new hampshire i
think we looked at how long it would
take to to own a cannabis establishment
and the commission i think they talked
about maybe three years but my memory
might be off on that uh that's how long
it takes to be a state senator for
residency in new hampshire too so you
know it's a pretty high bar they've they
put for cannabis uh
establishments in the commission report
um
so
another just a couple of things i heard
from previous uh people testifying that
i'd like to clear up uh we heard that
they're they're not required people that
are selling illicit substances the
cannabis and other things are not
required to pay taxes they absolutely
are required to pay taxes
um if you don't believe it just look at
al capone
uh he was nailed for tax evasion from
his illegal sales and if you look at the
uh
the irs website they'll tell you that
you have to report and come from all
illegal activities whether it's you know
cannabis sales moonshine sex work
whatever
you still have to report that income so
that's that's not a
legitimate argument
um
and i think less i mean i can keep going
but we're here all day so i'm sure i'll
fit in a few points later i know
everyone wants to go to lunch sometime
today and maybe dinner hopefully
um but
you know fast food is very dangerous too
you know the last thing i want is for
the state to take over
fast food i mean he'd want to have a
granite burger you know this is not
something we need to have the state
controlling just because they think it's
in our best interest when
prohibition was repealed in 33 virginia
was the first state to
uh enact a liquor control state and the
governor at the time of virginia said
that and i'm paraphrasing but he said
that the you know now that the
prohibition has been appealed they have
to do something about it and the idea
that they were going to the vetted
proposed with the liquor control state
it actually decreases the amount of
options people have we talked we heard
about things like edibles and vaping
products and other things
i'm not going to sit here and debate
those with you today there's a lot of
science on both sides of this argument
but if you have the state selling a
monopoly state monopoly on something
you're going to have limited resources
you're going to have limited competition
you're going to have other states that
will be ahead of the game in
the sense that they have more options to
supply the market
we don't want a black market and the
black market gets turned around too but
there's actually a gray market when you
have legalization but they buy illegally
and bring it from somewhere else legally
to an illegal state or even from the
state stores and sell it to someone else
that's considered a gray market i can't
answer questions later or even after
committee if anyone would like to speak
in a work session
i spent a lot of time studying this i'm
i've started several non-profits on the
boards of several substance use disorder
organizations recovery and treatment
centers and i'm on the harm reduction
coalition's board of directors as their
policy director
um so if you have any questions i'd be
happy to answer them
at some other time i'm sure but i'd be
representative
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question and for your
testimony we heard a moment ago that
there's
uh buyer's remorse in states that have
legalized this product sounds like
you've done some travel and you've
actually spoken to people in these
states
can you uh provide some context
as to if this is
a true thing
uh i i haven't we did we didn't travel
to most of these states we did travel in
the in states to the dispensaries
themselves the most it was remote
we talked to the the
the pot the cannabis are from colorado
and members of the commission from
massachusetts and other places
um at the time this is three years ago
there was no
remorse whatsoever that we heard from
any of these individuals as far as the
studies you hear about accidents and
things like that and teen usage uh i
don't agree with a lot of things you
heard in in reference to them being
drastically increased if anything uh
they decreased in colorado at that time
for for teen and young adult young usage
now there were increases in the in the
college age years range
but uh that wasn't a very significant
increase we heard increases of accidents
from an insurance study that was done
out in colorado and some other states in
that area
uh the details of that study didn't show
increased fatalities necessary that were
directly
caused by cannabis use they were
actually um
mostly fender benders and small and
there are more incidents reported
and when something is legalized you do
get more incidents reported you're going
to have more insurance claims
so if you want to hear about access
reports from insurance companies they're
going to tell you we had more claims
because something is now
you're not going to go to prison for it
it's a misdemeanor or illegal in that
state and also with uh underage usage uh
we heard about hospitalization we heard
from in colorado specifically their
state medical director i believe it was
about hospitalizations for uh ingestion
of you know poisonings so to speak of
cannabis in the hospitals and how that
increased
a huge amount in colorado and i the
number was
percentage-wise was a lot higher but if
you actually look at the number it was
not a very large number it was in the
hundreds of people going to the er
for cannabis no one died no one had uh
long-term consequences in any of those
cases in colorado
and i i mentioned a study that they
looked at there were over ten thousand i
forget the exact number but over ten
thousand uh calls to poison control
nationally before ingestion of a very
dangerous product that caused a lot of
people go to the hospital and almost
died
um and that was
laundry detergent pots so that's
remember the tide pod stuff
and i asked them i said so in colorado
you have this many people how many do
you know how many tide pod
poisonings you've had in your state and
you think it's more than the cannabis
suggestions and he's kind of laughing
he's like well yeah it's probably a lot
more
but they didn't have an exact number for
their state but it's it's kids get
themselves into all kinds of things i'm
all for safety measures to protect
children and to keep them from ingesting
ingesting laundry detergent turpentine
whatever there's a way to do it safely
there will be no further questions thank
you for your testimony thank you very
much
good morning i can still say good
morning
i appreciate the opportunity to share my
concerns regarding the important issues
of house bill 1598
i thank each committee member for your
service to new hampshire
my name is elizabeth broshu and i'm the
services director of communities for
alcohol and drug for youth
a central new hampshire non-profit or
organization
i'm also a certified prevention
specialist and the substance use
prevention coordinator for the central
new hampshire public health network
i oppose
house bill 1598
over the
past 14 years being a prevention
educator and professional in the public
health i've watched the effects of
decreased perception of risk on
marijuana on youth on youth
academic problems school truancy
juvenile justice issues
social problems and mental health issues
including anxiety and depression
youth have shared they believe that
marijuana would help them feel better
and in the end
making them making it all worse
i have parents calling me beside
themselves with worry about their
child's marijuana use
i have spoken to young adults who know
they are addicted to marijuana but do
not have the means or the resources to
get help
and even believing that if they if they
even try to
get help they will be ostracized by
their peers and even their families
i talk with educators concerned about
marijuana's effect on their students
grades and extracurricular activities
this drug is crossing all socioeconomic
boundaries
and negatively impacting our communities
and yet we're considering considering
increasing access to an addictive
substance
in new hampshire adolescent and young
adult marijuana use is a significant
concern
it has been a concern for many
years
and this was even before maine
massachusetts and vermont
legalized
the recreational use of marijuana
with marijuana legalization new
hampshire will see new high potency thc
products we will see the increase of
access as well as the increase in youth
use as other states have legalized have
experienced
we are already one-third
of our students in central new hampshire
using marijuana are we willing to
sacrifice having more
that surge
for the the
the possibility in 10 years
that they could
regulate numbers or even decrease in
eight points
it's not a risk we should take
we are also seeing an increase of not
only young adult use but adult use with
which will affect the work efficiency
and the capacity of new hampshire's
workforce and increased safety risks
created by impaired driving on our
roadways
our state will feel the ramifications
and it will hurt our youth our families
and communities when we should be
helping them during a serious mental
health and substance use crisis our
youth are experiencing today
if we are to effectively address the
drug crisis we must work to increase
proper preventive profession messaging
and prevent
addiction for profit
not encourage it
science tells us that the developing
team brain is especially vulnerable to
addiction
that is why addiction is often referred
to as the disease of adolescence
in your packet there is an insert why
prevention the escalation of drug use
during the teen years
you will see the surge of drug use
during adolescence between the ages of
12 and 20 and then it tapers off during
the rest of the lifespan
according to the national center of
addiction and substance abuse nine out
of ten individuals who struggled with
addiction began drinking smoking and
using other drugs including marijuana
before turning 18 years of age
this illustrates the need for more
prevention not less
if we legalize and commercialize
marijuana we will be sending the wrong
message regarding risk factors and
opening the floodgates to increase
access and use by our vulnerable youth
population
today's marijuana is not the marijuana
of the 1960s high potency thc is
marijuana of today
and the costs are insurmountable
with high potency thc comes greater risk
of anxiety depression and addiction
we are living through a serious opiate
epidemic and mental health crisis in our
state
to legalize a drug that multiplies the
risk of heroin addiction by three times
is a devastating miscalculation
the legalization of marijuana will only
serve to add to the problem of addiction
rather than help solve this public
health crisis
as a prevention educator and a certified
prevention specialist i see a dire need
for new hampshire to focus more on
prevention
prevention is stopping the problem
before it starts
we hear from other states that numerous
harms that legalizing marijuana has done
to communities families and youth there
is no safe regulations to legalization
when it comes to recreation recreational
marijuana or high potency thc
house bill 1598 is not good for new
hampshire it is not good for our
children
this legislation will hurt the people of
new hampshire and benefit only those
there being no questions thank you very
much for your testimony
the committee now calls kellyanne
mcglinn
hello everyone i want to thank the
opportunity to be here today
um i'm kaylee mcglinn a community action
member at raymond coalition for the
youth and i have a few words to share
regarding the impact this bill would
have on the youth if
hb1598fn was approved and marijuana was
legalized for recreational use the youth
committee of new hampshire will be
exposed to more outlets openings and
opportunities to gain access to the drug
even with the precautionary age limits
arranged within the law
teenagers in new hampshire are over 27
percent more likely to use drugs
compared to the average american teen
and according to the american academy of
pediatrics marijuana use has been shown
to delay mental development specifically
in the prefrontal cortex managing
self-control moral judgment behavioral
aspects
the hippocampus for learning and storing
memory and other cognitive areas of the
brain
i'm around
these youth in the process of becoming
our largest entrepreneurs government
officials and scientists every day
the potential of the future leaders of
our country could be stunted with
regular marijuana consumption through
these crucial developmental stages
and so i ask why should we allow this
hallucinogenic substance to be
authorized for personal use when
statistics medical studies and data is
proving that our teenagers are becoming
more familiar with drugs
i am part of a generation that has been
coerced through media for drug use and
now possibly reinforced by state
legislature
we want to protect our youth in such
uncertain undetermined times the
potential the future holds their human
advancements may be way beyond our
increasing normality of marijuana will
have a detrimental impact to the
children of our future new hampshire has
the third highest drug rates in the
united states with being the only state
on the east coast not to
legalize marijuana for recreational use
the united states drug enforcement
administration classifies marijuana as a
schedule one substance
schedule one substances have no accepted
and official medical use and high
potential for abuse
some other schedule one subjects in the
same category are heroin lsd and ecstasy
why are we encouraging the idea of a
drug in the same category as heroin one
of the biggest epidemics in the state of
new hampshire and permitting it for
personal use
another major concern over this
marijuana legalization bill for the
yeast is the dependence or inability to
act independently without marijuana or
to become a regular occurrence
teenager years are notorious for making
bad decisions due to the fact that the
mesolimbic region of the brain is very
active during these years
the mesolimbic pathway has an embedded
philosophy of if it feels good to do it
again creating impulses and temptations
as it is releasing dopamine and
glutamate
with these pleasurable neurotransmitters
released this causes a habit behind a
substance and that shows that our
teenagers do not fully take into full
consideration the consequences that
could happen because the fixation is on
the substance that once made them feel
good again
the mental habits and stretch they can
put on the human mind could be a mess
especially for a teenager and according
to the yale medical institute
adolescents using marijuana while in the
age periods of 12 to 18 have a
significantly increased likelihood of
developing schizophrenia and numerous
anxiety disorders
your choice today could be the
difference between exposing our youth to
a messaging drug that can delay
cognitive development and promote
dangerous decision-making or it could be
an act of protection to guard the
adolescents of new hampshire from
harmful substances becoming normal thank
there be no questions thank you very
much for your testimony
good morning mr chair members of the
committee thank you for hearing my
testimony
my name is neil hubacher and i'm the
director of cornerstone's church
ambassador network we're a growing
network of about 300 churches
um although we don't normally engage
directly in
policy
because of some recent developments uh
in the church ambassador network i just
felt compelled to share those and i am
testifying to be clear in opposition to
hb 1598.
so um
the two developments that i wanted to
share with you our number one
part of our strategy last fall was just
to begin connecting with senators just
small groups of in-district pastors
connecting with their senators primarily
just to honor them and say thank you for
your work
we managed to hit about 12 of them so
far five democrats seven republicans
and
again the purpose was mainly
relationship it wasn't based centrally
on policy but we would always ask the
senator hey what are your biggest
concerns for your district you know for
your 50 54 000 people you know what are
your concerns and
almost every senator in their top three
concerns in their district they were
mental health
and the addiction crisis
mental health and the addiction crisis
and so in light of that and actually in
light of i think it's uh deb narrow of
katie and our colleagues at kd you know
they've made that link between the
addiction crisis and mental health these
are big concerns and so in light of that
it just seems like this bill at this
time is ill-advised
the second development that the church
ambassador network has
experienced in recent months is
we started a collaborative so some of
the pastors of these 300 churches have
gotten together it's a mental health
collaborative
and it was primarily a response to the
dukovic
so the committee i am a little bit too
ambitious on drafting the original bill
so i will be focusing on the amendment
today
it is my understanding that the new
hampshire house has come to a consensus
on marijuana
and that it should be legalized in this
state
our current issue
is working out these details
do we want to tax cannabis sales do we
want to stay monopoly on sales etc
as we have heard in previous bills today
what this bill does is it's a backup
plan in case we do not come into an
agreement on legalization and pass it
this session
what this bill does is further
decriminalize marijuana possession
by removing any references to
misdemeanors for possession
it lowers the initial fine from 100
to 50
and lowers all subsequent fines from 300
to 100
and this would increase the possession
limit from three quarters of an ounce to
a full ounce
this also fixes what i believe was an
overlooked issue in the rsa that makes
it so that individuals between the age
of 18 and 21
can be charged with a misdemeanor upon
their first possession offense
i think we can all agree that we should
not be charging our young adults with
their whole life ahead of them with a
misdemeanor for simply possessing a
small amount of marijuana
these are all the things that i believe
and hope we can agree on
with that i asked the bill to pass this
bill with an ought to pass
recommendation and i will take any
questions the community might have thank
you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
i just have a simple question i can't
find in your
bill
how you would prevent
or what you would do to prevent
youth from using it
you know once it's out there
and it's
you no penalty to take it
you have to find some way
to not transfer that to
the younger people
thank you for the question
representative and uh
this bill
is just a very minor change it keeps the
current statute as it is so there's no
changes
in terms of
uh addressing that issue uh specifically
uh there is still a fine in place and
there's still uh the violation does go
up
in severity but uh
this bill does not address that issue
specifically and how it gets into the
the committee now calls representative
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
i'm in favor of this bill and i just
wanted to let members of the committee
know i said
far less than one minute
for my testimony i used to just support
medical marijuana and
my first term as a member of this house
as i saw that we're being inundated with
more and more bills
sometimes as many as a dozen bills house
and senate uh
per session that it's using up an
enormous amount of time so
it wasn't just the hassle and
aggravation that i saw medical marijuana
patients going through
that convinced me that we needed to just
legalize marijuana outright
it was the the amount of time that it's
eating up for the legislature so for
that reason i would i would ask you to
support this bill and support uh
decriminalization or even legalization
outright
the committee now calls lieutenant bill
thank you committee again for hearing my
testimony uh just for the record i'm
lieutenant bill bright with new
as with the other bills that
decriminalize or
legalize
marijuana or cannabis
we'll just take the same position that
we believe that there will be challenges
that come along with these
increased use
increased availability will lead to
and that will
lead to increased exposure to our
children
increased
issues with impaired drivers and so
forth
at this time we will now close the
public hearing
the committee will be in recess until
noon
uh
now
please
the criminal justice public safety
committee will come to order we are now
opening the public hearing on house bill
1348 relative to the legalization of a
the cannabis
thank you mr chair just one moment i
wasn't sure if you were on schedule
still because i know there was a bill
before
thank you mr chair uh committee on
criminal justice and public safety thank
you for making time for me today
my name is timothy eagan grafton two
sugar hill and i'm here to offer house
bill 1348 which is relative to the
legalization of certain amount of
cannabis
i think it's a bill that's time has come
since 2018 10 states
have passed legal adult use cannabis
right that's
roughly three and a half years ten
states
for our neighbors next door vermont
then michigan and illinois
in 2020 on election day in arizona
montana new jersey and then added into
new york virginia new mexico and
connecticut
as well
there are now 36 states that have
medicinal use like the state of new
hampshire does
what this says is our society and our
culture has embraced adult legal
cannabis as an option instead of alcohol
for social enjoyment or as pain relief
alternative to opioids more importantly
the most talked about 2018 unh
survey stated that roughly 70 percent of
new hampshire residents support
legalizing cannabis
then we should act on what the people of
new hampshire want
the economic impact of a home grow
industry that would be included in this
bill
is substantial
right now roughly 1500 is what someone
spends average in america to build a
home grow operation
if you said roughly one third of that
seventy percent of new hampshire
residents decided to do them grow
if that's applied then it's a minimum of
four to five million dollars of new
revenue in the state from
they would be patronizing hardware
stores
lighting companies nurseries contractors
electricians who would all then profit
from
the homegrow side of legalization and
homegrown
as well this bill has broad legislative
support from the house legislators who
we've seen bills pass who have been
thinking about pro-cannabis on both
sides of the aisle
and there
has always are willing to confer and
work together to try and bring a
consensus bill on legalization and
homegrown
moreover new hampshire has learned the
best practices and the worst practices
from other new england states regarding
legalization
and it knows how to move forward with
logical and sustainable legalized
cannabis for new hampshire residents
we are smart legislators who know how to
envision the future for our state
and the future for new hampshire is
legalized possession and homegrow of
cannabis
thank you
thank you sir
now calls lieutenant bill bright new
good morning once again um
one of the things that i noticed in this
bill that i wanted to point out to the
committee was
on line 24 it says cannabis infused
products containing no more than 300
milligrams of thcc
as far as a possession limit
while i am aware that in a lab setting
that level might be able to be tested
but as far as i
know there is no way for an officer in
the field to be able to test the amount
of thc
in an infused product
so that would be extremely difficult to
enforce
to have a limit like that
you would either a police officer would
be forced to either seize all cannabis
infused products
and inundate the lab or
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is frank knack with the accou of
new hampshire and we are here in support
of this legislation
the arguments that we have in support of
this legislation are the same we have
had for the previous bill so i don't
want to repeat what i've already said
uh just to say briefly that the war on
marijuana in new hampshire is wasting
our tax dollars it is enforced the
staggering racial bias
and the collateral consequences on
granite state residents are enormous so
we support this thank you for your time
the committee now calls the honorable
thank you members of the committee i
know it's a time to eat soon so i'll be
as brief as i can
um
like i said earlier when we were
studying uh legalization and taxation of
cannabis in new hampshire um we looked
at a lot of different things and one of
them was home grow and the issue came up
what do we do about home grow
and the example was thrown around that
um
you know we already have home display
distillation of beer and wine so you can
have up to 200 gallons as most of you
probably know of a beer wine of beer
wine in your home as long as it's not
it's for personal family use or and
you're not selling it
um and only 100 gallons if you you're
the only person brewing it in your
household that's a lot of wine and beer
to make for home use so
increasing the numbers have a few plants
and to allow an increase in the personal
possession of the mountain new hampshire
is is not even a big stretch it's the
minimum we should be doing at this point
there's no enforcement of the liquor of
home distillation unless someone is
selling it there is no one at the liquor
commission who goes out and checks to
see how much you're home brewing for
beer or wine
i don't foresee that happening with home
grow
cannabis unless someone sees you know
plants on uh from satellite from
satellite images or airplanes if there's
a large field in someone's yard maybe
they'll start investigating but
traditional home grow of small amounts
is not been an issue for alcohol and it
certainly i don't believe it will be an
issue for for cannabis in new hampshire
thank you the witness is excused
good afternoon i'll be very brief this
time for the record matt simon prime
alternative treatment centers and i am
speaking in favor of this bill which
would very simply legalize
cannabis possession and limited
cultivation for adults as i said in my
previous testimony this has been the
first step of adult use legalization in
nearly every state that has ended
prohibition for adults and there's no
reason that it shouldn't be the first
step in new hampshire
the questions associated with how to
best regulate cannabis production and
sales are somewhat complex and
maybe the criminal justice and public
safety committee isn't the only
committee that should be weighing in on
those questions frankly but this bill is
very simple
it merely answers a very simple question
what should be
the state response
to the adult use and limited possession
of cannabis the vast majority of granite
staters believe there should be no
response
when an adult chooses to grow a few
plants or possess cannabis or use it
and that's all this bill asks you to do
so i would encourage you to pass it
see no hands raised the witness is
excused thank you for your testimony
terry clayton
are there any members of the public who
are present who wish to testify that
seeing none at this time will now close
the public hearing on house bill
and just to address the committee
we are going to be in recess until two
o'clock
but we're going to actually be meeting
in our committee room not not in reps
hall
so
we're going to regroup in our regular
when we
reconvene at two two o'clock it's going
to be
in our committee room not we're not
b
foreign
anywhere
oh
i send you a master
hmm
uh
oh
yeah i did have it i'm so glad i made a
copy of everything so somewhere along
the line i guess i mixed mixed it up
where's
oh
huh
um
foreign
yes
oh
is
guys
right
this
now
uh
university
yes
uh
appreciation
so
you
uh
stacks
well today temperature's not too bad
so
he's not going to be here i don't think
i'm pissed at uh
lawyers
babies kids one of these kids either and
that's good
well you know several years ago
we were out in uh
oh somewhere in the eastern part of the
state oh yeah a
a man
beating a
young girl
you and i were together
several miles away so what the whole
team recorded
but
yeah so it's probably gonna interfere
well you know if you
it's like this little girl down in
manchester
um
yeah two years
have shouldn't have been looking for in
any way
that's euphemism for fu biden
yeah
somebody's got a let's go brandon
yes
um
is it hearing it too
be nice as daryl
yeah
are you speaking on that one
oh honestly
oh speaking of renny i talked to the
clerk he said we cannot switch one kind
and i called the clerk and checked and
immediately yeah i did one this year
yeah what are we going to do with that
one
i hope no
it's just
what mine
we were going to do that last year but
the edna killed it and said that there's
oh
okay
at this time i will be opening the
hearing on cacr20
and
the committee now recognizes
colleagues thank you i'm casey conway
state representative from dover
representing stratford county district
13 here now to introduce
cacr20
on behalf of the prime sponsor who is
in light of the overwhelming public
support for legalizing cannabis
many granite staters have asked why
can't we just vote on this like they do
in other states although new hampshire
does not have a process where
voters can take matters into their own
hands like a referendum much like our
neighbors to the east in maine
we do have a constitutional amendment
process
this is a unique case and i think it
should
we should seriously consider using this
method
to improve public policy
since the legislature and particularly
another chamber in this body has
repeatedly failed to act on cannabis
legislation
despite polls showing a super majority
of support cacr20 provides legislators
with another reasonable option
we could send the question to our
constituents and give them the
opportunity to decide the question for
themselves in november
the proposed amendment language is
simple it would add a statement to
article 2 the natural rights clause
establishing quote all adults shall have
the right to possess cannabis intended
for personal consumption just as article
2a protects the right to keep and bear
arms
article 2b protects the right to live
free of government intrusion
this proposed article 2c would protect
the right of adults to
excuse me possess cannabis intended for
their personal use
this is not a complex policy issue
cacr20 asks a basic question
and it deals directly with the
relationship between individuals and our
state government and i believe it is
entirely appropriate that we address
this fundament fundamental issue via
constitutional amendment
as the committee is well aware um i have
tried to i put forward bills to address
this via legislation i'm co-sponsoring
another measure this year
that is um
the preferred measure for making policy
in the state
this is a unique situation
in part because
for the last
six maybe longer years we have as a
legislature been unable to advance this
uh it's
uh we heard the term earlier it's it's a
charade it's one of those things our
constituents can't comprehend why we
can't get this done
uh and i hope that this year will be the
year that we defy that history um
so
obviously i'm continuing to support
those measures um but it's it's unknown
where those bills are going to go we
hope that or i hope that they will pass
we don't know that where that process
will lead but this gives us an
alternative approach
um i would argue that referring the
question to voters in the form of a cacr
not only is a reasonable option
it's the least we can do it's putting
the ball in their court and it's letting
us listen to them
so
there's much more in these
prepared remarks that i will i will hold
for later but um but that's the main
point here
and one thing i want to clarify is that
cacr does not
explicitly mention home cultivation but
it also doesn't limit the form of
possession that would be contemplated
you could argue that it would include
cultivation
but one could amend this to uh clarify
that on either side so with that i'm
happy to take questions
and i would ask the committee to
um i have a question if if you can
answer it
a cacr i believe requires a super
majority in both the house
the senate and the public
that's my recollection as well thank you
representative burt
um
and thank you for your testimony
why article two you know why not have a
special article that would add to that
you know why
put this on article two
well
it could go uh it could go either way
the reality is these are uh i think it's
it's
identifying a right that is significant
to new hampshire residents and those
other rights i believe are equally
significant
thank you for your you know mr chairman
for allowing me a follow-up
um
i remember seeing the roll call last
year
and i do agree with you about
letting the voters decide this
but there was a second amendment
uh cacr last year and
you
didn't allow the voters to vote on that
could you elaborate on that i could um
again
not my original proposal but i've
thought long and hard about that
including last year and i'm i'm here now
telling you that that was an incorrect
decision
uh on me representative of course
but
we don't know what they think on every
issue and i would love to know um
this question that question and other
questions i wish we had a referendum
system in our state we don't but
anything that we can get direct um
input from our voters i think
is appropriate even on things i don't
necessarily agree with
there being no further questions i thank
the witness for introducing the bill and
the committee now calls the honorable
thank you members of the committee oh
that's pretty loud sorry
um my name is joe hannon i'm here
representing the new hampshire harm
reduction coalition today
and we support this this cac people in
this to happen and i think it's it's
it's incumbent upon us to at least even
if you don't support the idea to give
the people the chance to vote on it and
let them decide that's what a true
representative democracy is about and i
think our republicans better for it if
we let the people tell us what they want
so i beg you please uh let this pass and
there'd be no questions thank you for
uh thank you um i'm jonah wheeler i'm
representing myself but i also work with
rights and democracy which is an
advocacy advocacy group uh here in new
hampshire um
i have
a lot to say about all these bills so
i'll just sort of condense it into this
one speech and won't go on too long so
don't worry about that
but we've all heard the arguments about
marijuana cannabis whatever you want to
call it
i feel like we all have someone in our
lives
who uses marijuana in one form or
another
it's not
meth it's not cocaine
the fact that we're still here today in
2021 in a state
that proclaims liberty and freedom live
free or die
debating whether or not someone can grow
a plant
smoke it on their own use i think is a
bit silly
i'm someone who supports freedom when it
comes to all things i think you should
have the liberty to do what you choose
if it doesn't infringe on someone else
and giving this to the people this
legislation and other legislation which
will legalize it and so on and so forth
that's exactly what this does
we have liquor stores
i could give you science if any of you
want science on the fact that alcohol is
far more dangerous than marijuana
causes more deaths causes more crime
causes domestic violence
far higher rates uh than marijuana does
the fact that we're again that we're
still here debating this in 2021 uh says
a lot about our legislature and
specific to this bill the constitutional
amendment giving it to the people i
think would restore some semblance of
faith uh in the institutions of our
republic i think you know if you look
talk to anyone who's not active in
politics nowadays i think you would hear
i don't really think that anything's
getting done for me up there or in in
washington i don't think they work for
me i don't really think there is a
government anymore that's that's the
conversation a lot of people are having
we give the people the decision
if we give people opportunity to make
their own decisions on something like
this
i think that is how we start to restore
faith
in our institutions
going forward
so with i don't know didn't have
anything written and i apologize for it
being a bit of a ranty but
i hope that the committee really does
consider what freedom actually means in
this country and if we're going to have
freedom
we should have actually if we're going
to proclaim freedom then we should
actually
instill that freedom in our country and
this is a small but significant way to
do that so
i thank the committee for my time
there be no questions i thank the
can you hear me
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is frank knack with the aclu of new
hampshire uh you've already heard my
more in-depth testimony this morning on
why i think new hampshire should end its
war on marijuana
just to add that the majority of
republicans independents and democrats
support legalization of marijuana in new
hampshire
we think it's appropriate that the
voters choose
or if the legislature chooses one of the
other options to fix it in statute
either way works for us we think this is
smart public policy
from a fiscal perspective from a racial
disparity perspective from a public
there be no questions thank the witness
is there anyone else who hasn't signed
up that wishes to speak on a spill
there being none i will close the public
hearing
and we will stand in recess for 15
minutes
i think he overestimated how much time
again
yeah
oh
i didn't know they were taking
applications
oh
which
you just kept coming back here every
year
um
is
foreign
um
mrs
probably still there right next to the
falls
uh
um
so it's adding something that isn't
there
itl generally i'm in favor of
this one right here
now
is
thanks
you talk about the one that's coming up
well yeah because it points to a place
in the constitution that doesn't exist
the constitution
they finally decided
he does have one he does have
one
sheep
democrats
uh
so that's why i wrote a letter to
oh
oh she said that oh yeah
multiple
most of the soldiers
even guidance from presidents took three
facebook
um
i've just given
okay it being 2 30 i'm going to call the
committee to order and open the hearing
agitant
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee um i am here to
testify in favor
of cacr
34 as soon as i can find it here we go
i am here to introduce cacr34 a
constitutional amendment to provide a
framework for cannabis legalization in
the state of new hampshire
i have a series of points today that i
want to make before the committee
and the first and foremost is the point
of process
please please please
do not vote against this when the time
comes specifically because it's the
wrong process and because it's a cacr
and not a normal bill i'll explain why i
think a cacr
provides the right foundation needed for
cannabis legalization going forward and
for the record yes i think it's
unfortunate that this
is one of the last and best avenues to
legalization that we have
in the form of a cacr i think it's more
unfortunate that a plant is legal
i hope by the end of today i will have
met my responsibility to convince you of
the merit of the language despite the
package that it's coming to you in
the language of the cacr says quote the
general court of the state shall make no
law infringing on the right to you the
use sale and cultivation of cannabis
for persons over the age of 18.
i chose this language specifically to
give the legislature implied regulatory
authority by setting the bar at quote
infringing on the right you may
recognize that language from the second
amendment i chose that specifically
i'm really really going to try to make
the following case without sparking a
second amendment conversation
um and at the risk of accidentally
invoking one i want to use the supreme
court's interpretation of that shall not
be in fringe language as it currently
stands in precedent this is not
specifically my opinion one way or
another this is the current starry
decisis as interpreted by the supreme
court regarding the 2008 heller decision
a decision which i believe was decided
correctly
and this write-up from a site called
libertarianinstitute.org
quote
after a narrow 5-4 vote
the supreme court held that dc's handgun
ban violated an individual's second
amendment right to bear arms for lawful
purposes such as self-defense crucially
the supreme court ruled that the right
to keep and bear arms is an individual
right unconnected with service in a
militia the court's opinion
written by the late justice anthony
antonin scalia was careful to make sure
the heller decision could not be
interpreted too broadly
quote from scalia
like most rights the second amendment is
not unlimited it is not a right to keep
and carry any weapon whatsoever in any
manner for whatever purpose scalia wrote
the court's decision in heller could not
be used to overthrow laws preventing
felons in the mentally ill from buying
firearms
the court ruled that weapons in common
use like handguns are protected by the
second amendment and that dangerous or
unusual weapons could still be
prohibited
i use this example specifically
not to take a position on heller or the
issue that it was debating but to
explain to the committee that i believe
a reasonable interpretation of the
president and starry decisis would
require a court to acknowledge the
legislature as having a right of right
in
inherent and embedded limited right of
regulation so long as those regulations
didn't impede the broader right
because of the specific language in the
cacr
the legislature would have the authority
in this instance to prevent you from
smoking in a kindergarten class but you
would have the right to smoke in your
home this kind of legal interpretation
was also solidified by starry decisis
with the first amendment in u.s versus
schneck in the famous can't yell fire in
a crowded theater decision and then
later narrowed in brandenburg v ohio in
that instance you can't legally call in
a bond threat but you can make a
statement disagreeing with the
government just like you would have the
right to grow cannabis and possess it
but not drive under the influence
i think this kind of implicit suggestion
of regulation authority is better than a
more overt statement
because it is in effect limiting the
regulation authority so that the actual
right of use sale or cultivation of
cannabis must be maintained in any
regulatory action the legislature
decides to take
i initially referenced the cacr as a
good framework and by that i mean this
puts the onus on the legislature to
craft cannabis policy
under the presumption that if it can and
ought to be legal and used by the public
over the age of 18 instead of well okay
if we legalize it what does that look
like
because i believe the latter ends up
being inherently more restrictive
for the benefit of the committee's time
i'm not going to give you a dissertation
on the popularity of cannabis
legalization in the state of new
hampshire you've heard it a million
times this year including just today
i won't tell you anything that you
haven't heard already i am simply here
to explain why i think this contains the
best guard rails possible to ensure safe
and effective cannabis policy that keeps
public safety in mind while also letting
cannabis users exercise their freedoms
and what my constitutional
interpretation of the language is folks
are allowed to disagree with that i am
one of the few lawmakers that comes to
hearings and says that i admit that i
don't know everything i would ask the
committees pass this with an otp motion
there we go
uh having just introduced a cacr knowing
that there's another one
would you to the extent that you can
provide
an explanation on the differences
between at the very least the one that
was just heard and your cacr
with permission from the chair to speak
on bills not currently being heard
yeah
thank you mr chairman
um yes i would be happy to um in my
testimony i spoke a lot about
inherent regulation authority versus
overt regulation authority
one of the other cacrs
that you will
be hearing or either heard
the last few words in it specifically
say
subject to regulation by the legislature
i believe writing those words there
specifically
create a wider opportunity for
over-regulation
versus the
inherent defined regulation authority
within
the language that this cacr has
the supreme court
espec in the state of new hampshire in
the federal one
can do a lot with a lot less language so
i believe
having
more
overt language there isn't helpful to
the project
regarding the cacr only having to do
with possession
um
you could make an argument that
possession goes pretty broad uh if you
consume cannabis you are possessing it
in your body
um but i believe that if you're going to
go the cacr route then it is best to be
as inclusive as possible
while providing the best guardrails so
i don't want to
speak negatively on another colleague's
bill i'm happy to
answer that the best i can but those are
i i have a quick question
um
with regard to the inherent ability to
regulate um constitutional amendments
as you i'm sure you're aware the the the
courts generally use a um
a test uh scrutiny test intermediate
stricter um
that
in itself could take years to
say the legislature were to pass some
type of regulation and it were
challenging the court before that could
get even heard or ruled one by the other
could take years do you think that just
leaving abroad like that is is
safe enough for the
for that period of time until it sorts
um
unfortunately cases do take a while to
percolate um
but i think
and actually this speaks to the
difference in language between the cacr
and the other one i just brought up
i think a legislature looking at the
words shall not be infringed
may be less likely to
pass
any restrictive
legislation
versus the words subject to regulation
by the legislature um
even that you know hesitation and
pumping the brakes for example i had a
bill
come up in ways and means this morning
uh regarding uh different tax rates for
different size businesses depending on
the wages they pay
um there was
consideration in the committee
on the constitutionality of that based
on some specific language than the tax
statute about
not having differentiating taxes i
happen to believe that you know because
the business profits tax is based on
size that that would be constitutional
but there were other members of the
committee that disagreed and i don't
know the state of the status of that
bill how it's going to come out but i
can tell you that that initial
hesitation was enough to make some
members consider
um
not to you know
pout on my other bill uh today but uh i
to answer your question i think uh
having that language in there uh would
provide a little hesitation for future
lawmakers
thank you
um there are no further questions thank
the committee now calls the honorable
hello again um promise this be the last
time i speak to you today
um
so my name is joe hannon and i do
support uh cacr34 as i do the other
cacrs today
um earlier i may have mentioned that
um
you know there was some discussion about
whether
federal laws would conflict if we
legalized
cannabis in new hampshire
most of you know that the 18th amendment
was written to prohibit alcohol in the
country and it was repealed by the 21st
amendment in 1933.
i still don't know which amendment was
passed to prohibit cannabis in the first
place
and i think because it's never really
been done that's just been assumed power
the federal government has taken and the
states have just kind of gone along with
it's not the first time it's happened in
history it's happened with many other
things we have
medical we've had a medical program in
this state for for several years now in
contradiction to federal law
and it did pass it's been operating it's
been doing well
uh we also historically have been a
state who has gone against the federal
government for other things we went
against the federal government in terms
of slavery
we fought to not send return
caught slaves back to the south we
didn't do very well in court but we
fought them we fought the fight in new
hampshire for our own rights and i think
the people of new hampshire deserve the
opportunity
to take
their own rights and vote on them in
in the ballot and on the ballot so
uh please i implore you to uh otp this
bill of this uh cacr
and uh even like i said if you even if
you don't agree with it let the people
decide and
that's pretty much all i have to say
thank you i'll be happy to take any
questions
there be no questions thank you for your
testimony have a good day
uh thank you chairman and
representatives for the opportunity to
speak today
my name is terry clayton i have a phd in
chemistry and i run an analytical and
product development lab in guilford
new hampshire
and i was asked to talk a little bit
today i do support the bills put before
you today
and i have been asked on
regular occasion about safety
efficacy and quality
if a cannabis program were to were to
continue forward so i wanted to tell you
a little bit about what i am doing and
then quite frankly if going forward
as cannabis moves forward in new
hampshire if there's anything i can do
to help people understand
from a technical standpoint i would be
happy to do so
so my laboratory i am
licensed by the dea to have controlled
substances on site and perform
analytical testing i am in process right
now to get
certified to assist in the tcp program
to
help quantify
the cannabis that's provided by the
dispensaries and
and some of the things that i've heard
from people is that
that today because there is not a
recreational cannabis program in new
hampshire
typically someone that wants cannabis is
getting it
probably through their network
probably in a ziploc bag
it's based on trust
potency is unknown
safety is unknown heavy metals
pesticides things like that
in it so i think the medical dispensary
program is doing quite well
there are lots of
instruments used regularly in the
pharmaceutical industry that are ready
methods all set to go
if new hampshire were to continue moving
this forward
and my lab as well as
other labs that i'm sure
would come along with the process
can certainly ensure
potency
presence or lack thereof heavy metals
so anyways i wanted to share that with
this group and if there were any
questions at this time i'd be happy to
take them
otherwise going forward i would be more
than happy to participate in dialogue in
the future
thank you i do have a question actually
given your expertise
are you aware of or have you heard of
any type of
testing that would be forthcoming that
would assist law enforcement in
conducting an on
on the roadside type of test for the
presence and level of cannabis in a
person's system
uh let's see so in in the person's
in the person's body
no i think there is some work being done
there are very low-cost kits
available it's called tlc where if um
if an officer or someone else can pull
someone over
is nervous about something that's in the
car you know you can test things on site
but i'm not i'm not aware of a
breathalyzer or or i should say a
non-intrusive type test that you can run
on the spot
okay thank you
there would be no further questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
representatives
anyone else wishing to testify this bill
cacr34
um there being none i will go ahead and
close the hearing on cacr34
please
oh
no
uh
um
foreign
oh
can't
hey
wonderful
oh
okay
hey
can we peel the shades down he wants to
testing one two okay
it now being 3 pm i will
call the committee to order and we will
the committee calls the honorable andrew
prout
thank you mr chairman i am andrew prout
representing hillsborough county
district 37 the towns of hudson and
pelham
this cacr would establish a right to
personal non-commercial possession use
and cultivation of cannabis
but explicitly permit laws seeking to
regulate or tax commercial cannabis
activity
looking at the calendar for today i
suspect you've heard a lot on these
topics so far today
so i'll try not to be repetitive
there are two reasons this is filed as a
cacr instead of a regular bill
the first is simple math it takes one
less vote in the body on the other side
of the wall
um
we're in the different room than i
thought we were going to be when i wrote
this though
the second reason is coming up this fall
the people of new hampshire will vote on
whether to call a constitutional
convention
that happens once every 10 years and in
the delegates to that convention would
be elected from the same districts as
the house and there is no equivalent to
the senate or the governor in the
process
given the popularity of legalizing
cannabis in recent sessions of the house
and according to polling data in the
general public this is also a viable
path to accomplishing the goal of
legalizing cannabis via constitutional
amendment
if we do not accomplish legalizing
cannabis in this session year of the
general court
i would be among those advocating for
the public to call such a convention
even if this khackar fails to make it
fully through the process to be proposed
by this legislature the hearings
discussion and votes on this khakar will
inform inform the voters and future
convention delegates as well
uh i promise to be brief so i'll leave
it at that but would of course be happy
to answer any questions the committee
there be no questions the witnesses
there being no further witnesses
um
we will go ahead and adjourn the hearing
i'll close the hearing excuse me on cacr
35 and the committee will stand in
oh
sounds good to me
hey do me a favor yes sir do us all the
anyways
you